good evening everyone - Rebecca started
sir quarter past 6:00 so good evening
and welcome to tonight's cert meeting of
the east area planning committee for
Stratford district council my name is
Danny Kendall our be a chair in
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and procedures set out in the
front cover of your agendas tonight
before we get going just a bit of
housekeeping if I could ask people to
make sure their mobile phones are turned
off or at least silent please and also
make you aware of the fact that we're
filming tonight's meeting it's going out
live as a webcast on the work councils
website but it will also be available
for you to review at your leisure on the
website tomorrow should you wish right
just a few introductions from the people
at chop here on my far right is and
banks will committee services at
Stratford district then Mason ash legal
services on my left is Richard Gardiner
our Planning Manager for the evening
then Neil hemstead Alice carnet Andy
Carter's somewhere in the room got Erin
Williston and Robert Parker Guildford as
well who are all officers who will be
presenting on various applications
tonight right okay that being said let's
go to item 1 apologies for absence at
non chairman thank you declarations
interest please so we'll start here
capsule crump item 105 application 17 /
0 0 5 2 3 / 4 king-size Rugby ride
Stockton I am known to the applicant and
will be on that one thank you the
reference I note that we need the full
number just the item is okay counselor
Perry good evening chairman and I just
like to take an interest in item number
seven white house farm either cooked
through client contact reasons thank you
will you be sitting out of a meeting for
that I will be sitting thank you
yes Kelsey O'Donnell good evening
chairman I would like to declare an
interest in item number seven I will be
speaking
councillor fielding say seven times well
speaking they're not speaking just not
taking part in the meeting thank you yes
Council Mills thanks mr. chairman I'm I
did number 10 I feel I might may have a
conflict of interest here so not
comfortable to sit out on that one thank
you very much any more
I just had my own for item seven
although it's completely non-pecuniary I
am I think I've taught the son of one of
the speakers
it's non-pecuniary I'll continue for
that though yes I'm sure I'm sure the
Mobile's will be turned to silent now
that's okay right lovely right minutes
of the meetings held on the 12th of July
you all can tempt me to sign those true
record thank you I'll do that at the end
right before we get started there's a
couple of things I need to bring to your
attention
first of all item six is going to be is
the recommendation is actually to defer
that pending further information it
needs to be received by the council
before we can proceed with that so I'll
put that to the front of the agenda if
that's okay so we can get that out of
the way quickly but that'll be the only
change to the alteration alteration to
the agenda and if I could also draw
members of the committee's attention to
the rather sizable update sheet
I think it's there's a lot there I'm
going to give you just two or three
minutes to read that if that's okay
thank you
we can tend to move on committee
excellent right okay so as I said a
second ago we're gonna move item six up
the agenda to start with this is
application reference 17 / 0 0 6 3 2 /
ful VAD Brooke barn lab rat rod Bishop
citizen it's for the proposed change of
use a redundant agricultural bond to a
holiday let and Associated works
presenting officer Andy Carter and even
just if I could just ask you the reasons
that we're being proposing to defer this
the reasons officers are proposing to
defer this when it's come to light that
the certificates of ownership that was
served been served incorrectly and as
such it's quite an unusual circumstance
the application becomes invalid at that
point in order to revalidate it the
correct ownership certificates will need
to be served and then we will go through
the an identical process to the one
we've gone through ok to contend to
defer this item and come back later I'm
have to propose it a second and council
brain just beat you to it all those in
favor of deferment please show thank you
right so we start with item four and
this is found on page 9 of your agendas
and this application reference 16 / 0 3
9 0 force / ful this for Jaguar Land
Rover Gaiden test center bamboo Road
Gaiden and British Motor Museum Banbury
Road Gaiden this is the construction of
a southern car park to include car
parking access drainage attenuation
removal an alteration of earth burns
landscaping erection of covered walkway
lighting fences and all other associated
works presenting this off presenting
officer is there Neil Hempstead over to
you thank you chairman the application
site is shown on the screen is Jaguar
Land Rover just to give a bit more
context to that the application site is
outlined in red so it's just south of
the Jaguar Land Rover
moving ground adjacent to the British
Motor Museum and just to the north of
gayden so just to give members a bit of
context to the application and members
may recall that some significant
applications developments were granted
for Jaguar Land Rover last year
including the gaiden triangle site and
the noise vibration harshness building
works are currently ongoing on site to
implement these and part of the
permission consisted of a southern
carpark with an access road so the
application before members at a moment
is generally in the in the vicinity of
the X dam permission and I've got a plan
later under permission just in the
presentation just to show the
differences between the between the two
so before what members tonight is a
l-shaped southern car park approximately
1,700 parking spaces an access road just
following the cursor they're a covered
walkway which effectively the route goes
that way and some associated security
fencing and with a drainage pond just
down there so just to give members of
context the difference between what was
previously granted and what is proposed
now the brook the blue line the blue
outline shows what was granted last year
so if you just follow that that's the
southern carpark there with the access
road going along so the changes are the
main access remains the same but members
can just see a slight deviation to the
access route there the southern carpark
has effectively more or less being
divided in half so it's it's smaller at
the southern boundary and move further
away from from gayden with car parking
added there so it's more like an L shape
now and that just indicates the the
covered walkway which I referred to
earlier so just giving members some
context to that so
that's the existing British Motor Museum
and the main jlr site there so the
carpark is going in this area here and
this area here to form an L shape no
members will notice at the moment this
area is used for for car parking for
test cars which use proving ground and
in in this area here there's a storage
area for for test vehicles so there is
parking in these areas at the moment I
should also point out that the buns
which had to be removed are just located
here and along here to increase the size
of the parking the members may record
the the last committee that permission
was granted for a an additional museum
building for the British Motor Museum
which is going in this location just
there another important feature to point
out is the existing tree belt which
offers screening to the application site
and that is to to remain and that's what
referred to in the in the committee
report so just giving a view from
outside the site if I can just zoom in
this is this is looking from Selvam road
so just to give an indication of where
that that is this is the the proving
ground and the the car parking area just
here and that is gayden village there so
just looking an arc effectively that
position there you can see the the tree
belt which I refer to in the previous
photograph and just given members of
context of the separation distance
between gayden and the application site
so the car park will effectively be
going in this area here with the access
road linking up to the existing access
into the site and that is gayden village
there so the distance between the
application site and the nearest
residence there
approximately 650 to 700 meters so just
looking at the car park itself and the
the extent of lighting proposed so this
is the northern element of the of the
l-shape if you like so the dark patches
you can see there are the the proposed
lighting to be erected
now how clear this is coming out on the
screen I'm not sure but you can see that
the the lighting the extent of the
lights bill has been plotted on the plan
and it's obviously closer to the light
sources you would expect but you can see
that it's only just extends beyond the
boundary of the carpark so there's sort
of double headed lights and single
headed and that will make a bit more
sense when I show some details of the
lighting in a minute and just looking at
the the southern element of that
l-shaped car park if you like and again
you can just see the extent of the
lights bill not really just extending
beyond that the car pockets itself and
just looking at the lighting on the the
access road here now the lighting has
been is going to be positioned on the
the southern part of the access road
pointing away from gayden and members
may have noticed from the for the
committee report that conditioners be
proposed for asking for details of
hooding to be applied to again reduce
the extent of Lois bill that would be
experienced so just looking at the
details of the lighting for the for the
main car part the l-shaped it would be
three and a half meters and for the
access road it would be six meters in
height it's a relatively standard design
for for both with single and the double
lights so the previous ones were six
meters with a very similar design for
the three and a half meters details of
the lighting the light head itself
members will note that the the head is
is relatively level thing as a five
degree angle with the the lighting
pointing down to again to reduce the
amount of spillage chairman there are
updates as detailed in update sheet
referring to additional responses from
counselors kettle and Harris and some
clarifications in respect of the
proposed conditions and Chairman the
recommendation is to grant planner
permission
subject to the conditions and notes as
detailed in the committee report and as
amended in the update sheet thank you
thank you thank you Neil okay let's go
to our first speaker then councillor
Claxton from Gaiden Parish Council
please
welcome counselor so you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
warning at the last ten seconds right
gate and parish council have engaged
with jlr and pegasus through regular
liaison meetings and have made our
position clear in order to preserve what
is left of our rural environment no
further contribution to light pollution
can be tolerated as mentioned in one of
the objection letters on a cloudy night
in the winter the current lighting gives
the effect of a dawn glow we appreciate
that jlr have designed their lighting
with regard to current health and safety
legislation however it must be
considered this legislation would have
been designed for urban locations where
the public have access and additional
lighting would have been in consequence
of from inconsequential the legislation
must therefore be considered
inappropriate for a secured facility
with the proposed lighting to be
positioned on the very top of the hill
in a rural location I would point out if
you look at the iOS map that is the
highest point of that Hill that Jared I
have attempted to minute but minimize
the lighting by reducing the height of
the stanchions though I believe this is
offset by increasing the number also
they intend to implement the reduced
lighting periods and preferential use of
the car park to daytime employees this
appears to be somewhat overcomplicated
and unnecessary if the lighting is
appropriately designed a well-designed
car park would keep pedestrians and
vehicles separate until the pedestrian
is in the vehicle therefore low level
lighting should only be required for
pedestrian routes moving vehicles should
have their own lights to guide their way
I would like to state two pre-existing
examples the original jlr East car park
as an as minimal stanchions and the loop
has has minimal stanchions and
illuminated bollards the later East car
park has an excessive amount of lighting
even when clearly empty the Aston Martin
secondly the Aston Martin Northeast
carport
has minimal stanchions on the periphery
of the carpark and I believe
supplementary bull art lighting this
would indicate a reasonable person a low
level of lighting design is possible and
permissible and that the produced
lighting scheme is excessive and given
the elevated
rural in location inappropriate Gaytan
Parish Council has no other objection to
the application I would also like to
point out that although there is
screening from the hi there LAN di or
the main carpark I don't believe that
screening continues down past the
roadway maybe we could have a look at
that picture again but it's it is the
important thing is it is again I don't
think it's Neil has pointed out that
that is the highest point of that hill
where this lighting is going to be we
already have a severe problem with
reflected lighting on doubt days any
questions from the committee
yes Council bonds they are aware of that
concerns but they don't they've taken
them on board as best as they can within
what their design parameters but however
we would contest that having that car
park there is gonna with what the
lighting there is just the lighting
we're objecting to thank you any further
questions
no that case counselor thank you very
much our next speakers thank you for any
questions okay thank you
right so same rules apply you have three
minutes if you have any if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end and
I'll give you a warning in the final ten
seconds over to you so good evening my
name is Laura Empress
as agent for Jaguar Land Rover besides
me is mr. Matthew Colebrook who is the
lighting engineer for Jaguar Land Rover
he's here to answer any technical
lighting question should any arise
remembers our offices have introduced
the application is made to make the
efficient operation of the Jaguar Land
Rover site with the provision of an
alternative southern car park in the
southwest of the site it follows the
similar approval of an application back
in somewhere last year for the same
sized car park as you officer noted it
moved slightly further northward into
the site the application includes 1,700
spaces as per the previous approval
along with the cupboard walk we're
getting access into the main investigate
at the front of the JAL ArcSight the
revision of the parking is for the
employees as part of the Jaguar Land
Rover sites and accords with the
principles and policies of your call
strategy namely policy a s11 the car
park may also be used from time to time
by British Motor Museum during their
events as overflow car parking weekends
that type of thing the application has
been designed to include all of the
drainage attenuation measures and
removal of the buns to the south of the
site to enable the car park to be put
into the site and landscaped as much as
possible on the certain past bit the
matter of lighting as raised by the
parish council has been something that's
been discussed as part of the game forum
and the project team have discussed them
in past accident and try to allay their
concerns over the original submission
and the lighting that we've got there
the level of lighting is what we
consider to be proportionate to the need
before the car park and what we need for
it to be in safety terms and what the
safety standards require us to do and
it's at the minimum level that we feel
that we can achieve that we have tried
to adapt the the level of car parking
lighting to reflect the difference basis
we've got and that's why we've got the
six metres have dropping down to the
three and a half metres the scheme is
modern in its design and specification
so it removed the sky below means in
full accordance with the gaben lighting
strategy which was approved as part of
the 2006 permission and it offers a
number of improvements including the
hooding strategy and also being part of
the lighting management strategy of
gaming which looks at the hours of
operation the management and the
the use of the car parks to minimize the
amount of time the lights need to be on
your officers recommended conditions in
this regard and we support those
conditions overall we thought the
development has a limited impact on the
built-in battery environment and has
been sensitively said I'm taking an
account of all of the concerns that have
been raised accordingly we feel that the
quality meets
all local local and national bank policy
and we support your office's
recommendation and we thank you for your
time thank you any questions small
committee
yes councillor fielding and from Edge
Hill the buildings are very noticeable
are you going to be affecting any any
trees or you're going to cut down any
trees so the only tree removal would be
to get the access point in we wouldn't
be cutting the trees down on the edge of
the site so if nil if you could bring up
the access plan or the plan that shows
the site location where the access
curves along the southern part there and
it points there where nails got the
cursor there would be a small amount of
tree removal there to get the access
road 3 yes
bearing in mind that Edgehill is part of
the COS world a a OMB we already have
severe lighting from the Army in the
bottom of the hill what effect is the
Jaguar landed the lighting going to be
as far as Jaguar Land Rover on the
horizon from Edgehill case is part of
design we've got and guidance for with
reduction of obtrusive light so
effectively it sets a lot of standards
for us to do not increase in any way in
light pollution in the surrounding area
and we've designed to that that document
the edge reforms part of the British
standards and we exceed quite
dramatically
for that so we can Rick it I think from
there we can say that we will not be
adding to under the guidance we will not
be adding to any like pollution in
surrounding area yes it counts a Crump I
think mr. Tobruk is unsurpassed in but
you might better add to it um I'll see
the council site they felt the proposed
lighting was excessive inappropriate I'm
obviously hardly paraphrasing but
something like that there's any chance
it could be mitigated further and this
is the one you've probably heard and in
percentage terms what is the increase in
terms of light pollution especially as
it's the highest point on the site
question feel free to jump in if I get
the technical side of things it's been
designed to minimize the height of the
lighting to the standard that we need to
get we watch to get safe access for
people using the car park and that's
where we've got the difference in in
Heights and the standards do dictate
things like roadways need to be lit to a
higher standard to a car park so we feel
that we've minimized as much as possible
in terms of the pollution point I think
I'll let Matthew adds that one but it's
difficult to say at what percentage and
we we can we can say that we're not
making the situation any worse I think
but it is all dependent on what by
pollution we have in the area as
standard so the guidance states that the
guideline states the requirements to not
increase the light pollution and we've
adhering to those and it's it's it's not
an easy answer to say what percentage
and that yeah I've got councillor Barnes
then council apparently I was just
wondering whether the light pollution in
your eyes from these is very similar to
previous application
I mean are we using the same light
[Music]
like July last year's part of the bigger
site its princely I believe the same
level of lighting but obviously it's
moved closer into the site so rather
than sitting firmly on the bottom of the
gel our boundary Council Perrin
thank you good evening to you both and
the posh council made reference to
lighting have more focused lighting for
the pedestrian walkway areas was there
any way that if one actually just did
that that you was there any
consideration to having some form of on
the ground reflectors for headlights of
cars to direct them into spaces like you
would find on a country road there would
be no street lights but as long as the
the car parking area was marked with
some form of on the ground reflectors
not talking cat's eyes but I think
you're getting my drift just just sort
of answer the parish councils concern
about having safety for pedestrians but
drivers being able to use their
headlights to enter and exit the car
park in a safe manner yes so the the
guidance the British standards that we
designed to actually therefore the safe
transport of people and and cyclists
within the space it's not for the cars
so it's for the people to move around
the space safely and see what else is
around them so that's effectively we
have to have a uniform light across the
whole car park because there would be
two pedestrians moving across that
carpark and they differ on the use of
the car lock so if it's a if it's a high
usage car park and then you need more
like there's more stringent guidelines
that you have to follow so in this case
we were in the middle of the the
guidelines that we need to adhere to but
it is for pedestrian safety pedestrian
access across the whole car park not for
the cars I know the parish
asked us to look at bollard lighting
bollard lighting if I understand mark
doesn't have a sky glow to it because
it's lower down and it's not hooded to
see you actually get more sky sky glow
as a result of bollard lighting in terms
of the area that we need to cover in the
lighting we need to get you triple the
amount of lighting if you put if we had
to put borrowed lighting into it it
doesn't resolve the issue
in practical terms council milf thanks
mr. chairman these lights obviously for
Health and Safety you may not be able to
answer this question but do you know if
any ladies worked very late at night at
jlr you would use that car park I would
assume it's a distinct possibility
yes council fielding the a and B being
consulted about the effects that this
will have particularly the lighting in
the area can you a major development as
this application is so I'd be very
surprised if the a or and B weren't
consulted on the application whether
they've chosen to I think respond it's
okay I mean from your perspective I
think you've answered that maybe it's
one we also bring that later for point
of clarification and any other questions
no no case both thank you very much okay
we can go to our ward member counselor
kettle
welcome counselor so yeah you know the
routine you have five minutes over to
you mr. chairman members Jaguar Land
Rover as I said before is a great asset
and we are very privileged to have them
in our district and I'm very privileged
to have them in my ward they are very
very good about consulting with parishes
and with board members with their
monthly meetings days or meetings which
have been referred to and the basis of
this is a I have no objection to
whatsoever but you won't be surprised
because I've brought it up before I find
it so disappointing and none of you who
live in villages I know what most of you
live will be have ever lived next door
to a an airport car park or a large
supermarket car park where you have very
tall lights understands it isn't a
matter of them being directed or having
a low luminescence pointing down and LED
lights are much more efficient than
previous lighting and that is a great
improvement but the fact is if you look
exactly where the cross was long as long
as the mouse is not moved by Neil that
is on the edge of a reach and what we've
seen in gayden parish with the
development of the dual carriageway into
jail R which is an improvement is what
we call locally the Starlight Express
you can see it all the way across the
valley from the gate of the hills behind
gayden to Burton's asset towards Edge
Hill because you're looking up from
underneath you're not looking down
you're looking up the a and B from the
top of the hill you will be looking down
I don't have a problem sorry John
with the Aon B I notice in your
but what we have here is all the local
villagers will be looking up Bishop's
will be looking up to it like hornies
will be looking it up to it later on
will be looking up to it and what we
have here is 6 meter stands in a what is
still in a rural setting it isn't an
urban area it is a great asset of the
entire Jayla and aston martin facility
but there has to be a line drawn
somewhere in the sand and I think this
extends beyond that 9 LED lighting is
incredibly efficient and having a
significant number of lower lights which
has been suggested would reduce the need
to have six meter stands all the way
along at the perimeter which is on the
high point of the Battle of the hills
above gaming why do we have to have it
when we could have things that could be
shaded by trees you can't get six meter
trees growing in a comparatively short
time you can get trees quite quickly to
climb up to three and a half meters and
give that sort of shading but also that
three and a half meetings by link being
so much lower will have a much lesser
impact when you're looking from a way
the shading will be far more effective
when you're shading there than when
you're shading up here and therefore I
hate to continue an objection I think
this is an important that obviously
logistically this is an important change
to the carpark but it's getting to the
stage of blighting the local communities
not just Gaytan but other parishes
within my patch and other ward numbers
patches as well and I really think we
should look at an alternative approach
to this lighting even put another one on
the table that says there must be a
better way one that actually begins to
fit into the countryside rather than
developing further lighting not
because it's going down but we're
looking from down that is the issue and
if I think if you look around there are
alternatives which are much more
sympathetic to a neighborhood if we had
a great one mister building here you
wouldn't have it you would have Baba
flashing all around which would enable
people to access grade 1 listed
buildings with no health and safety
issues whatsoever in the country we
drive around on country roads without
any lighting cars don't need it people
do ba 10 seconds Thank You mr. chow
thank you okay any questions for the
ward member no okay it's council kettle
thank you
right points of clarification then wants
to start calipari thank you can Planning
Officers advise whether they sought
advice from a specialist lighting
consultant themselves in reviewing this
application we didn't go to a specialist
lighting consultant but we did consult
with our environmental health team which
is typical of this sort of application
to us and they raised no no concerns no
objection to the application yes counts
of building we didn't because it's not
the size of application that you would
do given the distance which is about
five kilometers away from the a OMB we
wouldn't have to consult with them we
did on the larger development which I
referred to earlier and they didn't
raise any objection in respect of of
that counselor Perry thank out Smith
Thank You chair can I ask the officers
for a bit more in-depth explanation of
the MPPs paragraph one to five which
makes reference to
light pollution from artificial light on
local immunity intrinsically dark
landscape and nature conservation in
terms of its impact honored on an
application of this nature yeah I mean
if effectively that is the the approach
that we would take in terms of having a
look at any application for lighting we
would have a look at impact on local
amenity we would have an impact look at
the impact on sort character of the area
which we've done in this case and also
nature conservation that the which is
mainly to do with ecology as part of
this application the impact on bats has
been assessed as part of the part of the
application process and we've liaise
with ecology one thing that I would
probably raise which has also taken
place in the area just move the mouse is
that there is some additional
landscaping works which are being
undertaking at the moment in the ecology
area down here which is part of the part
of the application site here and the
spoil from this site is being deposited
in this area where it's being the levels
of the land is being raised quite
considerably and that will perform some
sort of screening to residents of gayden
as well so we have looked to all the
aspects which are part of paragraph one
to five as part of the the assessment of
the application councillor Milton thanks
miss chim yeah just trying against my
minor the the height of this say six
meters yes
but when we get when we go close to
airport even I think Wells will have a
sort of a shorter lampposts how did it
compare with that do you know I mean how
does it compare with normal lamppost in
a in a street um I honestly if I'm being
honest with you that I couldn't give you
an answer to that I suspect it's
probably comparable but I would be
having a guess you mentioned that in
order for construction to take place
there will be the removal of the land
buns and in front of the trees will that
have any impact on the amount of light
that seen from the neighboring villages
if we just go back to I think I've got a
plan that shows the extent of thee so
that that's the extent of the of the
bonding which is to be removed mm-hmm so
to the would that be to the east it
wouldn't it would have less of an impact
probably the major impact is we're not
the major impact that the impact would
be the removal of the of the Bund to the
south here looking back on the
photographs that is negated to some
extent by the extent of the the existing
tree line there which i think is
probably brighter on the screen up there
than it is on mine and there is some the
whole of the Bund isn't to be removed
because it's now being moved south
further back into the site so there is
part of the bundle still be there but a
significant amount will will be removed
but the existing boundary treatment
there combined with the conditions that
we're looking to impose in terms of a
management strategy and a hooding
strategy officers consider that that
would be enough to negate the removal of
that bond as well
when you look at questions points
clarification should go to the debate
caps bonds I can understand the concern
about Elijah in the countryside we're
not actually sort of in the countryside
I think the world member said a
starlight
I think it's called starlight Road I'm
not sure exactly what it's called
and but there's 12 meter lives
I see the concern if we could ask Land
Rover to reduce them a little that's as
much if we can do but as I can see how I
can't see any real pollution issue in
the respect of refusing the application
so I'm you know I'm happy but obviously
there is a lot of life there there's
going to continue to be a lot of light
there and with this road whatever it's
called and that you can see that for
miles so I'm obviously concerned but by
lepak you approve the proposed the
application thank you nobody else
yes council fielding in Perry my
feelings are that there is a lot of
light pollution in the valley between
Edge Hill and the Jaguar site from both
the army can kind tomb Gaiden and
anything that can be done to reduce it
particularly the height of the post
holding up the the light and the
increase in the treeline will go a long
way to help to sort these problems out
of but it does need to be done because
it's it's just getting personal
worsening Perry Thank You chair um well
I have I do have great sympathy with the
parish council and and the ward member
but what I'm looking at at this moment
is this specific application in front of
me there is already existing light
pollution in the area
so it's you know it's we're not just
looking at this on its own in a single
unit and just by going through it and
the whole process I can't see a planning
reason that would be strong enough to
refuse it so it particularly in view of
its economic viability in terms of from
another perspective in terms of what jlr
bringing to the area it is with great
regret and I just hope perhaps the
management of the lighting on the
carpark is is managed sympathetically
and also that the environmental team at
Stratford District Council keep a close
monitor on the light pollution so that
it is very carefully monitored to
minimize the harm councillor O'Donnell
in council Crump
thank you chair and I think it's a fine
balance isn't it between providing a
safe environment for people in a car
park I'm also appreciating the financial
viability of Jaguar Land Rover being
there and also accepting the fact that
there's already light pollution I just
wonder if there could be an adaptation
to the light that's being proposed what
the would go further back picking up on
what the ward member said thinking about
shorter Lunt posts such they've got as
you drive into London because of over
I'm just thinking there must be other
ways of looking at this while still
providing the light that's needed and
what you can't refuse it on planning for
a planning reason you can surely see if
there's any adaptation that could be
made so you're still keeping that lovely
balance you've got with liaison with
your local communities but and
appreciating their feedback whilst also
servicing the facility of jlr okay I'll
just reflect on the question very
quickly and I come back to you at this
change is confirmed week if that was
something we wanted to do to change the
heights that would be a separate
application window we couldn't do that
at this point no I think you need to
make a decision on that it's exactly
over so that's a separate point
thank you okay I've got cancer Crump
next say in the update see there are
safeguards regarding conditions for the
lighting management scheme the proposed
covered walkway so I think we are
started to look at the conditions and
look at lots in detail so as long as
we're happy with the lighting and
women's game and make sure that's again
enforced probably I think we're covering
a lot of the vices there conditioner 15
the hard and soft landscaping details
with the bucket again could be
potentially strengthened or amended to
again help the situation but I think we
have got quality conditions on there 17
conditions that are trying to safeguard
the local environment so I'm relatively
happy with the application that council
Mills thanks for each image is almost
the same sentiment says cash flows don't
work this evening there's a balance here
between safety and light pollution I
just wonder if everything had been done
to minimize the height of these these
lampposts perhaps I should have asked
that of the applicants earlier I'm just
fine
it'll be kind of really good plenty
reasons they'd say no to this it's it's
a difficult one they've got to have
lighting all night you can't just have
this no lights no car park for light and
it comes on and off it's even causes
more problem so I'm gonna think on this
one mr. chairman thank you well we've
got a proposal from councillor bonds to
grant the application do I have a
seconder at this point council brain
second do you want to speak on it are
you happy the agenda were always
concerned about light pollution
I'm sure known Jaguar Land Rover have to
come up with the best solution for
lighting all the SATA terry contour tees
is
objection there's a parish councils have
offered no objections at all and I have
to say the ward members including
against the kettle offered no comments
before tonight so should we go to the
vote on this so it's been proposed in a
second at the week grant the application
all those and of course with the updates
as well that are in the update sheet all
those in favor please show o5 chairman
and those against Sui Chairman thank you
therefore the committee resolves grant
application reference 16 slashes zero
three nine zero four slash ful and we
can go to our next item which is item
five on tonight's agenda and on page 35
its then as application reference 17 / 0
0 5 2 3 / ful Kings house rugby Road
Stockton and is for the change of use of
main house and two-story outbuilding
from residential accommodation to office
use and a number of other bits and
pieces are well but all that Alice
presenting officer go through those
won't you Alice
Thank You chairman the application site
which denoted by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located on the
edge of the village of Stockton the
application site which is outlined in
red on the plan comprises a large
dwelling and outbuildings within a large
plot the site is covered by a tree
preservation order and a public footpath
runs to the southwest of the site and
bride away to the north the existing
site is third by two accesses
one on to rugby Road and the other on to
Knapton road full planning permission is
sought the conversion of the dwelling
known as Kings house to offices under
use Class B 1 the building would provide
offices for a single company planning
permission is also sought to convert the
existing brick built out building from
ancillary storage to a storage and
workshop at ground floor level and staff
room at first floor level additionally a
new outbuilding is proposed adjacent to
the east boundary of the site to provide
additional storage space for grounds
maintenance
equipment as well as office storage
associated works include the demolition
of an existing stable range alterations
to both site accesses and laying down of
hard surface parking areas in terms of
the conversion of Kings house itself the
only external alteration relates to the
provision of a ramp to the south-facing
elevation as has been outlined in red on
the plan all other elevated elevations
would remain unchanged this slide shows
the proposed south-facing elevation plan
with the ramp detailed and a photo of
the existing south-facing elevation of
King's house beneath turn into the
conversion of the brick built out
building the only external alteration
relates to the insertion of a window at
first floor level into the East
elevation which again has been outlined
in red on the plan with the exception of
repairing and reinstating existing doors
and windows that other elevations would
remain unchanged this slide shows the
proposed East elevation plan and a photo
of the existing east facing elevation of
the outbuilding beneath here the
elevations and floor plan of the
proposed out building to provide
additional storage space can be seen
this photo shows the dwelling of Kings
house as it currently stands and here
the brick built out building proposed
conversion to storage and staff room
here you can see the gated access to
Knapton Road just about here with the
text with the timbrel stable Range
proposed for demolition on the left-hand
side of slide the proposed out building
would be sited adjacent to this boundary
here this photo is taken near the
intersection of the Knapton Road and
rugby Road the timber stable range can
just be seen in the distance just about
here on the other side of the road with
the application site of King's house
behind these trees and again on this
time of Rugby Road the application site
behind the trees the other access onto
rugby Road is just about in this
location here members should know that
there is an update to the application
which is detailed within the update
sheet chairman the recommendation is
through
the application subject to the
conditions as detailed within the
committee report as well as the
additional condition detailed in the
update sheet thank you thank you else
and just confirm it is here only here
for scale of development there's nobody
objecting to this well right let's read
our first speaker councillor Collison
please chairman of Stockton Parish
Council so you have three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end yeah give you a warning at ten
seconds thank you
this application when it came before us
had the full support of the Parish
Council after we discussed it in detail
architectural II and historically this
is the most important house in the
village and the application is going to
maintain the layout of the internal
rooms virtually unchanged there are lots
of architectural features inside ceiling
roses architraves moldings windows that
will be retained according to the plans
the weekly group themselves the
applicants have been very approachable
and discussed all their plans with the
parish council and they've been a medium
or two the suggestions that we've made
this application will preserve what is a
really beautiful house in the long term
and possibly in the long term it will
provide some employment opportunities in
the village and thereby it's difficult
for us to see how Kings house could be
developed as residential presumably as
apartments that would make any economic
sense this application reserves that
preserves the house in its entirety and
I think or we think the parish council
that the loss of one residential unit is
more than outweighed by the preservation
of an important building thank you mr.
chair thank you any questions the parish
council no okay thank you very much okay
don't think I can see Katsura cheese in
the room so we don't have a ward member
points of clarification anyone cares
I'll presume this is only because of the
size of oh yes in the green belt it's
purely scatter scale development I'm
quite happy to prepare you well unless
anybody wants to go say anything else on
it in debate I've got a proposition for
an asset and seconded that we grant the
application she'll get to the boat all
those in favor please show you know mr.
chairman Thank You committee therefore
resolves to grant application route 17 /
2 0 0 5 2 3 / ful and the addition of
sorry I should say there was the initial
conditions as well but I don't think
anyone's I think everyone's happy with
those
okay so we've dealt with item 6 as well
so we can get item 7 on page 59 of the
agenda tonight
okay this application reference 17 / 0 0
2 6 1 / ful and 17 / 0 0 2 6 2 / lbc
this is for white house farm it look at
ships to understand the description then
is for the demolition of existing block
work extensions and open fronted car
shed and conversion of an agricultural
into three dwellings together with the
erection of a new 3 bake airport
presenting officer is Erin weather stone
Erin over to you
Thank You chairman the application site
lie to the west of it look at village
certain within an open countryside
location science identified by the black
dot on this plan and access by an
existing access track to the south a
site light in a surface water drainage
concern area and an area vodka light or
potential this light hoods application
site outlined in red within the context
of the access to the south as shown here
this slide shows a proposed site
location fan site planet and block plan
the application site falls within a
cluster of buildings which includes the
host building which is a grade two
threatened barn in its associated
curtilage drifted barns the host
building retains the courtyard formation
which can be seen on the plan with a
central court child area retained just
to give you an idea this is the
threshing barn here and a courtyard
formation White House Farm is a great
elated building and lies the northeast
of the application site on a higher
level and this is White House farm just
here this valley has its garden located
to the south of the building and the
yard to the north the art of the north
is used for housing of livestock namely
camels and pigs and the yard is just
shown in this area here Atilla south of
the site lines one into White House Farm
Cottages which have their gardens
located to the south these dwellings
have elevations with habitable windows
facing toward the southern part of the
application site for the north of the
site light other closed neighboring
dwelling which is new White House farm
which is this building here and a number
of agricultural buildings shown down to
the right-hand side of this plan
planning permission a listed building
consent are sought for the conversion of
the grade to threshing barn connected
building to three dwellings proposal
includes associated worked on the
erection of detached carport shown to
the south of the buildings on a site
plan so just to think just in this
location here the carport
conversion with comprised of three new
three-bedroom dwellings the parking area
for the development is shown to the
south east of the buildings and a three
bay car park is also proposed to serve
the dwellings the - Daria's indicate the
parking spaces so you can see just here
and here
the application site would be divided
into three with private garden areas for
each dwelling as shown here so unit one
is this section here with its garden
shown to the left extending up in this
area unit two has its garden in this
area here
I'm unit three which is this L shape
single-story dwelling has its garden
areas shown here the central courtyard
area it will be surface with a gravel
surface and that's a communal space to
be retained the guards will be enclosed
by postal rail fences and the existing
boundary wall with the white house farm
to the right of the plan will be
retained I just got the mouse this area
here low brick wall under timber
postural fences proposed here this
slider is existing elevations of the
buildings which are proposed to be
converted gray to threaten barn it's a
larger section which you can see here
and it's internal courtyard elevations
shown on the bottom this slide shows
photographs of the external courtyard
facing elevations the photographs are
taken from within the application sites
and this larger section here is a grade
two threshing barn this is the wall
which faces onto White House farm and
the yard area so that's the access here
this slider is the internal courtyard
facing elevations for the buildings
which proposed to be converted with
threshing barn here this elevation is
currently stable so you've got the
stable doors which you can see just here
the location of the photographs is shown
in the bottom of the slide
the proposal submitters a resubmission
of planning application 15 /at 0 0 9 6 9
film and its associated listed building
consent the main changes to the revised
scheme include the removal of the two
extensions which is shown here and here
an internal reconfiguration and removal
of a glaze war which was internally
proposed looking through from top to
bottom our now go through the key
changes that are proposed with the
elevation on the top elevation the
modern shelter an extension
proposed to be removed and you three
windows were opposed within the
threshing barn so the new windows are
here here and here
this elements proposed to be removed
there's also a window proposed here
moving down to the next elevation which
is facing White House farm all the
existing openings including the windows
the doors are proposed to be fixture and
blocked up respectively and a carport is
also shown on this elevation so these
openings were posed to be fixed and
blocked up and the doors retaining book
fixed and blocked and here's a carport
that's proposed the next elevation shows
the south west facing elevation the
openings are proposed to serve the
retain here on the gable up to be to
retained just showing here as existing
these are glazed openings which proposed
to the Obscure glazed new glazed doors
are also proposed here for unit 3 to
lead out onto the garden area proposed
the final South View elevation takes
looks to retain the existing openings
with a new opening shown here the
carport is also shown to the right hand
side of this elevation this light is of
a post internal facing courtyard
elevations the North West elevation
shown to the top left of the slide seeks
to reduce the stable doors into windows
as shown the North East courtyard
elevations seek to retain the existing
openings and introduce a new window to
serve the family room of unit 1 just
looking here so this is the new opening
here these are existing openings to be
retained moving down to the southwest
courtyard elevation it seeks to block up
the existing opening and introduce a new
window which is shown just here and a
new glazed element here finally the
southeast courtyard elevation seeks
retaining existing threshing barn
entrance doors shown here and here and
how this area glazed this window is
existing and existing windows are to be
retained this slide also shows the
difference in ground level across the
application site as you can see here for
unit 1 the accommodation is on two
floors but it stepped down compared to
the threshing barn you see the change in
ground levels just about here this
slider is the internal layout of the
proposed dwellings which comprised of
three three-bedroom dwellings the
development is set across two levels
however unit 3 which is the l-shape
dwelling shown to the this section here
is single story only unit one has
stepped accommodation internally which
is shown going from the hallway down to
the lounge room can see the stairs just
going down to accommodate the change in
ground level the courtyard is here which
is proposed to be a communal space and a
carport shown to the south the dotted
lines indicate the modern additions
which have proposed to be removed which
is here and here looking at some
photographs this slide here is a
photograph taken on the approach to the
house building from the southern access
tract the red arrow shows the
approximate location of the buildings
this photograph was taken from the
southern access tract on the approach to
the application buildings White House
Farm House committee into the top right
at the photograph and one into White
House cottages shown to the forefront of
the image so the coffee is one and two
and what house far the gardens shown to
the front of these dwellings this
photograph shows our building which is
post viewed from the southern access
suppose to be converted looking at the
relationship with White House farmhouse
on a higher level and the courtyard this
photograph is looking back wouldn't want
one into White House cottages shown to
the left of the image and a building
which was proposed to be converted to
the right the carport would be in this
approximate location here in the garden
just behind this photograph was taken
looking along the elevation which faces
onto White House farm
you can see what house farm to the left
of the image their yard is shown just
over here and this is an access tract
and these openings are proposed to be
fixed in shirt there are no updates on
the update sheet there is a verbal
update which confirms a member site
visit was carried out this afternoon and
in attendance were councillor Kendall
councillor Mills councillor fielding
councillor O'Donnell and myself as a
case officer thank you
Thank You Erin excellent right onto a
few first speaker mr. Chris Rosser
please sorry I should say counselor chip
I shouldn't it's a village meeting isn't
it mr. Chris roster German chair of
Ithaca parish meeting please thank you
welcome sir you have three minutes
if you remain seated for any questions
and I'll give you a warning at ten
seconds if that's okay thank you over to
you
my name is Chris Rosa and I am the
chairman of Ithaca village meeting it is
considered by the majority of the
residents of it ticket who have made
representation to me that the concerns
raised over the previous applications of
this development remain unchanged
there's concerns include the access from
the farm tract from White House farm to
the what got Huntington Road is
potentially hazardous particularly when
considering the increased usage that
will be generated if this development is
permitted this road can be busy with
fast-moving traffic at times people
getting to in the fair work the school
run vans lorries farm vehicles cyclists
joggers horses etc it is worth noting
that a recent planning application on
the other side of this road and close to
the White House found turning was
refused partly on the grounds of traffic
hazard a major cause for concern is the
effect that this development would have
on the businesses currently being run at
White House farm namely Joseph's amazing
camels and a working farm any livestock
enterprises seven days a week 365 days a
year commitment and both businesses
often have to work antisocial hours and
at weekends there is potential for
disagreement caused by newcomers who may
not be familiar with the necessities of
country life which could not only sour
neighborly relationships but worse still
could affect the running of these
businesses I visited White House farm
recently and viewed the site of the
proposed development on the ground I was
left with a firm conviction that the
insertion of three dwellings in such
close proximity to the existing houses a
matter of feet increases would have a
significant detrimental effect on the
social and economic well-being of the
people who currently reside at White
House
and would diminish the quality of their
lives there may be however a perfectly
good case for the conversion of the old
threshing barn into a single dwelling a
simple sympathetic transformed
transformation could both conserve the
barn and provide a very nice home thank
you thank you any questions please for
mr. Raza yeah okay so thank you very
much to our next speakers Sally
Blackwell and Rebecca Fawcett I've got
you read both registered together oh and
David Wright I'm sorry at the bottom
there yes please if you happen to come
up together all right okay so as with
last time we have three minutes between
you have not to split this up Rebecca
myself speaking I'll go first okay
over to you I'll let you begin right
thank you it still remains the case that
there would be harm caused to the
heritage asset the threshing barn
resulting from this scheme it would also
constitute unsustainable developments
due to increased reliance on the private
car these are two very strong reasons
for refusal of parent permission and the
applicant has accepted that they exist
the absolute is arguing at this stage
that the public benefits arising from
the preservation of the listed barn is
sufficient to outweigh both of these
aspects of harm we think this is a very
weak argument because it assumes that
the only way to preserve this listed
barn is with what we consider to be a
contrived and poorly designed scheme
three houses the reality is that a
reduced scheme comprising of a single
dwelling with stabling and other
outbuildings could offer a formal
sympathetic route to preserving the old
bones without causing harm to the asset
and having a fraction of the
sustainability impact as mentioned
previously this committee colluded Locke
concluded last year that one dwelling
might be okay
but three was over development and
unsustainable as this application
differs very little from the previous
one in reality we ask you to stand by
that conclusion and refuse plan
permission thank you thank you now that
some of the members have made a site
visit we hope that you understand better
the points that we have made over
development lack of sustainability and
adversely affecting the amenity of the
neighboring houses and businesses it
should be noted that if the building is
within 400 metres of the curtilage of a
listed building and is not to be used of
the accommodation of livestock protected
building means a permanent building
normally occupied by people this is from
the farmers guide to planning by Defra
the application at Nineveh farm for
three dwellings was turned down due to
the dairy and David Smith Ryland had to
go to judicial review to stop housing
that shared a party more with a cattle
yard we consider this a similar case yet
in this case the Mastiff regime the
threshing unit development can be built
right next door to a livestock yard as
you have seen from the site visit if
that bothers the people living there
they can complain and the livestock must
be removed the environmental health
report says there are no objections how
the report was done over a fortnight in
March when our business is that it's
seasonal low period and flies an odour
is significantly less than in summer
this is not representative of our
business for 75% of the year assumptions
have we made on spurious evidence we
asked Edward Bill Chartered swear from
Sheldon Knight to do a report for us and
this is what his conclusion is in my
previous experience the occupiers of new
residential conversions can be
relatively affluent persons who have
moved from urban corner conurbations to
enjoy the peace and quiet that the
countryside can offer however I believe
in this scenario many conflicts are like
too likely to arise with potential
purchases not being fully aware of the
full nuisance that a business such as
this may incur we are extremely
concerned about the effect of this
application on our business now and in
the future thank you thank you
that's perfect timing any questions
please cancel bonds we live in the old
farmhouse White House farm I'm afraid so
you are next to one of the problems is a
big problem with surface water drainage
there are very few ditches now because
of the big fields and the water pours
off down the side down the we can look
at the where the garden of units that
with their the water paws off the fields
down there and I mean really really
pause I am posted a video of it when it
was raining very heavily last year and I
don't think this has been accounted for
by the application at all with the
sewage where they have placed the septic
tank is very close to the pond and we
think again if there's flooding there
that the pond could be and the stream
the brook could be contaminated I only
have one question I'm sorry I may have
missed it at the beginning of your
statement mr. Sasa you've mentioned some
guidance from Defra which again for me
yes of course so this is guidance it's
the farmer's guide to planning by Defra
and it's in the planning laws it says
that it's talking about livestock
buildings specifically and there's a
contrarian in that you cannot put a
livestock building within 400 meters of
what they call a protected dwelling
hospital school houses however you can
put a house within less than 400 metres
of a livestock yard and in in this case
you're talking well right next door
actually which is
fortunately something a law that is in
place which perhaps should be looked at
in basically contradiction is thank you
how try to confirm that that's okay any
other questions please no in that case
thank you all very much you can move on
to my next speakers thank you our next
speaker is mr. Steve Bromley please the
agent for the applicant welcome to prom
me no and you yes I'm sure you aware of
you have six minutes which a combination
previous two sets of speakers if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end
over to you you German this second
application introduces a number of
design changes that have been made to
address the concerns of the appeal
inspector the inspector dismiss appeal
only for design reasons he commented on
all planning issues raised by the
planning authority by local
representatives and by neighbors but
only dismissed the appeal for design
reasons he found all other aspects of
the scheme to be acceptable the key
amendments have been to remove the
proposed extension that on plots one and
two thereby restoring the buildings to
their original layout and appearance and
as a consequence reducing the size of
the dwellings
we've also amended the internal
alterations the listed threshing barn to
comply with inspectors comments the
changes we have made preserve the
character of the threshing barn
including its setting the inspector and
your officers have looked carefully at
the impact on neighbors and the rural
business next door but neither consider
the impacts to be harmful with these
improvements to the design the public
benefits of preserving the designated
heritage asset outweigh the less than
substantial harm that would be caused by
a conversion during the previous
committee chair members discuss the
application and counselor Mills said
that he could not see what had changed
between the last application and this
one well hopefully the amendments have
now been made cleared in the offices
explanation also chairman you expressed
the view that the last meeting that
there's a feeling that there is an over
development of the site let's consider
the factors that might lead to an over
development firstly the first issue is
whether the site is large enough for the
number of dwellings proposed this scheme
is for just three dwellings on a large
site providing substantial areas of open
amenity space well in excess of the
minimum areas recommended in the
council's informal policy guidance the
level of parking provision can be an
indicator of over development in this
scheme there will be generous on site
parking provision with no risk of
parking over spill on to neighboring
properties over development can lead to
a harmful impact on neighbors in this
scheme there will be no overshadowing
or overlooking of neighboring properties
there is nothing to indicate the amount
of development would be excessive in
terms of demands on infrastructure and
services or impact on amenity and
character I would also draw your
attention to the comments of the
appeared inspector who at paragraph 14
of his decision letter commented and I
quote the council has contended the
scheme would be an over development of
the site the number of units proposed is
not in itself a concern end of quote
on the issue of traffic at paragraph 33
the inspector comments and again I quote
directly in any event of I have not
found the amount of traffic associated
with the scheme to be harmful end of
quote
chairman when you analyze the issues
there are no factors that would suggest
an over development the council has a
long history of allowing and indeed
encouraging the conversion of
or buildings to dwellings particularly
were conversion safeguards important
buildings I encourage you to accept the
officers recommendation no Chairman I
would just like to address a comment
that did made by previous speaker the
Defra guidance has been misinterpreted
and is wrong the different guidance
simply points out that you need planning
permission for a building high housing
livestock within fall within 400 meters
of a protective building ioud wellick it
doesn't say you can't Health Planning
Commission it's just that most
agricultural buildings are permitted
development but they require planning
permission if they are within 400 meters
and often planning permission is granted
in those circumstances Thank You
chairman thank you mr. Bromley any
questions
yes council burns this application is
here to address concerns that's all I
can say is those absolutely correct his
concerns were designed that the balance
was not right there were they desired
did not do enough to preserve the
character of this heritage asset if we'd
got the design right in his view in the
first place he clearly would have
granted planning permission yes
counselor Crump I think it's mr. Wright
said in his opinion or the fish's
opinion it was contrived and poorly
designed and could have been done much
more sympathetically I might be slightly
paraphrasing Bob I just wondered what
you could settle out and then I've got
another question as well right well we
did work very closely with the Planning
Department with the conservation officer
we had meetings with them and we did
amend the design as a part as part of
that proposed
process there was a huge amount of
detail consideration went into the
design of this internal details of
timbers to be retained and added to a
considerable amount of attention to
detail there are very few alterations to
the external fabric of these buildings
it's not only the threshing barn which
is a listed building but the whole group
is within the curtilage of a white house
form and therefore is important from
that point of view a lot of attention to
detail on design again to show the
sustainability of the obviously where it
is its location again your comments on
that please so you just press the button
again I think you said sustainability in
relation to location yeah well the
cotton inspector did comment on that
point but again this is your planning
balance isn't it
your policy is Ted and sets a general
presumption against development in rural
locations but you have to balance it
against at any public benefits a
well-known public benefit is
safeguarding our heritage and so once we
get the design right that balance is
complete and it allows development in
rural locations plenty barn conversions
in rural locations they other questions
no mr. Bromley thank you very much we
can go to a ward member now please
counter O'Donnell
welcome counselor so you have five
minutes I think you know the routine if
you remain seated for any questions at
the end over to you
Thank You chair and committee so after
the site visit this afternoon
um I think again I'm going to echo what
I mentioned in my previous presentation
about this one of the concerns is
obviously lack of sustainability you
can't access a site without a car and
that would have to be reliant on a
private car with a sturdy set of tires
and a good suspension and contrary to
NPP F a paragraph 55 this development
would relay rely heavily on the use of
private car and the roads to the site
are not of good quality and there's a
safety aspect of agricultural vehicles
used in the tracks throughout the day
and not it not being ideal or ultimately
safe for those seeking a healthy
lifestyle the families walking or
cycling up and down to their properties
and given the fact the residents have
offered to buy the land for agricultural
purposes I don't believe that
residential is the only option for this
site I do believe it's over development
to the site and I would just question
when they're saying that something is
not doing development to the site how
much of that plot is actually
residential property are you taking just
a slice the plot or taking the size of
what's going to be occupied by buildings
because it does seem like it's over
development and it does feel more like
urban infill than what you'd expect on a
nice rural farmstead which this the
current residential area is and it's not
respecting cs8 historic environment
protection and enhancement paragraph 5
or CS 15 distribution of development
paragraph 3 where the design of the
development is well related to and can
be readily integrated with existing form
of settlement it's poorly designed one
of the master bedrooms is fully adjacent
to what I call camel alleyway where the
camels are walking up and down or being
popped into the the lorries they need to
take them up and down the country for
the various work they're involved in and
that often happens in the early hours of
the morning it is of note that two of
the reasons the planning inspector gave
her dismissal with
lead to increased reliance on the
private car and they created an
unreasonable living conditions in one of
the units and I think that still stands
whether you've taken off of the small
extensions or not I don't believe that
concerns have been fully rectified all
your committee's concerns regarding its
application which was overdevelopment
unsustainable location and harm to the
amenities and I don't think we can
underestimate the harm to a you know a
successful rural enterprise it's had 10
years history you know it's our job to
support the rural economy and we're
talking about public service and public
interest in you know allowing rural
applications going through but we have a
public interest in preserving our rural
economy especially when it's Aurora
Ward's such as the one I represent and
if we look at Edward Beals report the
severe from Sheldon Bosley he noted that
there is potential nuisance issues if
this if this goes ahead because the type
of people who buy converted barns
etcetera are not your rural workers they
may not be used of the noise and
potential nuisance of continual
movements we were there today at around
3 o'clock it was quite a quiet time
actually on that farm but it was noisy
you could hear the camels you could
certainly smell the camels you could
hear all the noise around them so I
don't know day in and day out and
especially in the height of the summer
how that would actually pan out I've
tried to find out more about what the
environmental health officer actually
thought I phoned up but they could not
release the information about the times
of his visits I understand he visited
within a two-week period three times in
March we don't know what time of day and
that's sort of quiet time for that farms
farms business I think that's worth
bearing and bearing in mind and also
this business because its success but
he's looking to expand into a camel
dairy and that one in but will also
encourage camel breeding now when the
calves are born they're not born such as
this sheet parrots that one time in the
year it's throughout the year which
leads to increased traffic with vets
visits increased noise and increased
disruption and if you're not used to
that I think it would be how living next
door to it so I think it needs to be
taken into account because then that can
lead to potential nuisance which would
link in with the Nineveh farm where it
was turned down because the dairy
application and I also refer back to
was mentioned earlier with a Smith
Ryland case whether it was farmers
trying to protect their livelihoods by
trying to you know draw our attention to
the impact that development can have on
existing agricultural businesses and
also highways actually turn down as was
mentioned earlier on the Crump's which
is just over the road from there and
that was due to poor visibility on a
minor rural road it's a tricky area to
exit to navigate as you leave and I
would question the overlooking because
the arm cottages are overlooked with a
new development and why is the glass
being opaque if you can't have a look so
I question whether things aren't being
overlooked I think they are 20 seconds
and I yes I support the residents in
opposing this application thank you
excellent any questions for the ward
member council bonds was here was to
address concerns of the inspector so
it's my understanding that concerns
about design and living space because
one of the units was going to be too
small but also it there were concerns
raised about increased on reliance use
of private car and unreasonable living
conditions in one of the units and I saw
that you know if you look on can we show
the picture of what I call camel alley
which I think makes the eye way look a
lot wider than it actually is here that
that adjacent wall Peter on the on my
right is actually the rear of the
proposed unit and when you want when you
we went in I went into the barn today
when you're in there you can actually
hear all of you know all the
agricultural vehicles going up and down
the horses beautifully clip-clopping
outside and the camels moving and you
know that White House when they work
really hard to keep it clean and that's
that takes a little noise you've
probably okay any other questions yes
Scott Smith thanks Jim penny and I
probably should have asked this of the
earlier you said about a nuisance is
yeah what time of day do they start can
I say servicing the camels I shouldn't
say that
what time they stopped moving around and
and this at nighttime as well I think
that's a really important point actually
today's councillor Mills because it's
not just around the camels you know the
general farming takes place but these
camels go nationwide and often are used
in in media engagements and they have to
be transported and it's my understanding
that transportation could start at 2:00
in the morning it takes time to get
these camels loaded up and then travel
up and down the country to where they
need to be for various engagements and
it's not going to be done quickly and it
can take a long time it's getting a
family in a car but to get camels loaded
up I think takes a fair whack of time
and an amount of people to make that
happen and that can be throughout the
early hours of the morning as well so
it's quite anti-social and ask for the
you know but that's the nature of the
business any further questions
councillor done well thank you very much
right points of clarification
okay councillor brain was first
encountered a couple of questions on
conditions really icy within the report
from but we heard from the objectors
about a pond and I wonder if any
consideration is given to news because
if septic tanks alonside sewage and
waste is supposed or that's run off
somewhere with ecology at County Council
on the application they've raised no
objection but recommended a condition
with respect to drainage the conditions
are proposed to have the surface water
and found drainage to be submitted in
approve and that'll be in consultation
with our Building Control team it should
be in there if it's not it would be
under the drainage condition that's
proposed
councillor bones I was just going to say
the conservation in our kudex here I was
going to ask you if I could
it's the only way to preserve these the
conservation architects here for another
ice and I can answer I can answer that
question the previous inspector
considered that this was the only way to
preserve these buildings and gave that
weight to outweigh this is
sustainability huh their points of
clarification I think the question I had
about was at sustainability so the main
reasons from the previous inspects
decision which did the preservation of
the listed building but it was to do
with design and sustainability of the
location you get more information on
sustainability what you say on that yes
so the previous proposal I've got the
plans to 5/32 this is a previous
proposal and looking at the floor layout
the internal layout now been amended
there was a glass screen proposed
internally which was referred to in the
inspectors report that's now been
removed and the two extensions of family
room shown here and this extension with
the lounge on this unit here have now
been removed as part of the new proposal
those were racist concerns by the
inspector the other concerns raised was
with regard to this window serving the
bedroom and that's now on the proposed
plans we've got a study and library at
this first floor and also the other
bedroom but we're satisfied that that's
not an unacceptable living accommodation
in terms of sustainability is an open
countryside location but we've got
policies in a s-10 which talk about the
conversion of a building if it's got
architectural merit subject with being
the optimum viable use of the building
and therefore in those cases that's
where you look at the planning balance
to look at whether or not you'd be able
to support an application in those
isolated locations thank you right
should we go to the debate yes I want to
go first Council Mills thanks mr.
chairman
Wow well I didn't wait a start on this
out personally I think that it's it's
just in the wrong place
just it's in the middle of a working
farm I did ask the board member about
the nuisance value if they are being
moved around it say two o'clock in the
morning or early house morning I can see
all sorts of problems where this is a
planning reason or not about there again
all sorts of problems in the future I
really can and which may have an adverse
effect on the existing business and it
may affect and come up from people who
move their savers we granted that move
there no chetan came up they don't like
chemicals moving around 2:00 in the
morning that may be stopped and the
whole business sort of has a detrimental
effect on it to me it's it's in the
wrong place I mean to get to it my word
I'm reluctant to take my car down there
this is a third time ER visit this site
not writing it I didn't really want to
take my car down there and I really wish
I hadn't I mean could have done any good
at all I did it on both tracks you know
I came the other and the exit onto the
road Road what could road it wasn't good
I can see the few problems of but the
whole thing just is just in the wrong
place miss Jim it's a middle of a
working farm it's just not good I just
doesn't like it so I'm afraid I might go
with the officers recommendation mr.
chairman thank you okay
Council bonds I went on a site visit
some years ago now I think when he first
started really October 2012 the County
Council were not happy to be the
entrance now then but it changed their
mind which is not a help it isn't an
ideal site for for this sort of
residential situation and if we're only
here for the situation of looking at
amendments which appears to be what we
are I think we're in
a weak position but it isn't an ideal
site we've got to try and save the
buildings in the middle this is mrs.
okay sometimes done this they're great
against the barns but because I think
it's quite quite a difficult one
obviously the the highway is one which
was one of the potential issues is they
our Highway Authority so I and I haven't
no objected that's one of the arguments
out of the way whether they were still
regard the site to be well-designed in
layout and is it over developed we've
heard from the the object is that they
felt it's contrived and poorly designed
and yet we have the mr. Bromley saying
that it's that's why of safeguarding the
local heritage asset and maintain its
future use so I've done particularly art
this one but I'm still having difficulty
on on what grounds we can object or
refused counsel about our brain just a
clarification really I think that Peter
said that we looked just looking at an
amendment but I would the description of
the development doesn't say that so
we're not just looking at an amendment
are we no just to clarify it's a full
application listed building consent it's
not an amendment what it is is it's in
effect an amendment of a previously
dismissed escape my concern chairman is
isolation and on the long track people
can't use vehicles i I think we they're
going on the saga it's an unsustainable
location
you are my thoughts having been on the
site visit today this is a really finely
balanced one I'm I'm struggling to find
really really strong clear grounds to go
against this but there is something
about this site that while I was walking
around the whole site today I just kept
feeling that it just wasn't quite right
and I think it's the same thing you were
thinking council mills which was it was
just in the wrong place if this was
being put in the middle of a village
maybe there were some you know some
working of the central buildings in the
middle of a village you didn't find this
makes perfect sense adapt them that sort
of works it's in the middle of an urban
location it would work but this isn't in
the middle of an urban location it's in
the middle of nowhere and again if this
was being tied to agricultural use and
these were agricultural workers
dwellings I'd say well ok I can sort of
see it but that's not what's being
proposed here it's being proposed to be
free what I think to look like pretty
expensive looking individual dwelling
houses right next door to a functioning
agricultural farm again it just doesn't
seem to work for me but there's three of
them there's the numbers too many if it
was one maybe I could see it working
again it would sort of make sense it's
just not quite tying up for me the
reasons I'm coming up for it right now
and I'd like you know best committee to
tell me what they think of these broad
reasons if that's okay so they've got
three reasons the first is that it's not
in keeping with the character of
existing development it's also an over
development and poor design that's
reason one but I'm looking at the second
one is the overall sustainability of the
location in that it's fine for an
agricultural location but not for three
dwelling houses both in terms of access
and the road access is abysmal I wasn't
particularly happy with what's happening
to my car either today councils look at
the suspension at some point and my
third point is the potential harm to the
existing amenities in terms of the bill
that the business nearby I think that
might be a slightly weaker one because
I'm not sure how those two tie up those
by three reasons for going against the
officers recommendation at the moment
I'm not proposing
I hear what people's thoughts are in
terms of those being my reasons what do
people think it would have a negative in
my to put myself in the position of well
if this wasn't an agricultural business
if this was north of camels if it was a
Mahal in chard with lots of lorries
going in and out every day would we
still be saying well this is fine build
houses next I think we'd be looking at
very differently we'll be saying well
there be a number of movements all night
we don't know when they're gonna be it
would be thinking well that would cause
I don't acceptable impact to the people
to the community of the both I think
both sides of this obviously in terms of
people living in the new dwellings but
of course to the people in the business
as well I'm not sure the thing two
things work together that's what I'm
saying much convinced some quite there
yet counts the pants
because I didn't get on this side busy
that won't be boy but it was fairly sort
of yeah good business if you understand
me me third one is the weakest to the
point so I'm putting across here what
about the other two what do we think
with the character of the development
over development at the site and poor
design yeah it's just the site and
sustainability access okay so that's
those two points leave the other easier
to thread a camel through the eye of a
needle and this I think yeah okay
anyone else want to comment at this
point okay Richard what do you think the
main okay let's drop the impact on the
business amenities so it's just the
desert the over developments and
sustainability that we're talking about
what you think okay obviously in this
case members will need to have regard to
the previous inspectors decision which
sets down a line in the sand and that
has significant weight in my opinion
what the inspector said previously in
terms of the character and the design
the applicants are sought to address
that by removing the extensions that
were causing those concerns and making
other changes that that Aaron has gone
through so that leaves us with very
little to actually object to if we're
going to give the great weight that the
inspectors decision should be given in
my view in terms of the overall
sustainability again I'd point you in
the direction of the inspectors view
heat up the view that yes it's an
unsustainable location it's not normally
where you'd grant certainly not a
new-build house but in this case that's
that way by the benefit you have of
giving some historic buildings in this
case they're listed giving them a future
by giving them a permanent use through
which they'd be kept on going into the
future and that's another plank to
sustainability that is the ongoing use
of the buildings so whilst it might be
unsustainable in one respect increasing
reliance on the private car that was
significantly outweighed by the ongoing
use of the buildings I'm allowed to
disagree within the specter I just said
is unsustainable full stop in cooking
you said the other way I just is just
unsustainable
get Richard best way to pull this is
that officers only application that's
gone for what was the application of the
amendment of the original application
but does this mean to say that they're
going to be the best application that
would come forward if you know I mean
yeah how do we are we rushing in yeah
it's will this be the best use that will
is maintain it or could there be a
better use and could be wait for a
better use that's I'm trying to say and
it might be it might not be possible I
think I can understand why the inspector
came to the conclusion that he did
because as we all know the returns on
residential are much greater than other
uses and to convert these historic
buildings would be quite a big input in
terms of finances to do a proper job and
to do the right thing because they're
listed buildings so I could understand
why he came to that conclusion so I
think it would be very hard to argue
against that to say well hang on I think
does it better scheme out there I'm not
sure what that better scheme might be I
think you could be left with the
building's just left because they do
they they've been left now for some
considerable time but they'll only
deteriorate the longer it goes the more
they'll fall down whether we think
residential is the only thing that
appears to be what the applicant once
I'd say I think if we do refuse if we
should probably lose on appeal but you
know we exist the ideal place to run
bears is council brain I find this very
very difficult chairman I mean should we
accept against unsustainability you know
turn them into dwellings you know that's
what we've got to consider but I think
after gray with cancer Barnes I don't
always agree with it
right then we're on very thin ice if we
go against this application considering
what the inspector said before although
we are we're in a position where we've
got the inspector that said very clearly
what he thinks would be acceptable all
right short of us throwing out toys at
the problem saying well we're gonna keep
a disagreeing with the inspector he
helped well he can overrule us we
disagreed on whether we think it's
sustainable peace as it is we think it's
a poorly designed and contrived
development he thinks well we can we can
infer I suppose from what he said before
that he will think this is okay I'm
forced I'm coming down on the side with
you guys which is really where where are
we going with this I mean you know
trying to move it forward I'm not fully
supportive of the application but by
thoughts were drivers have proposed the
application when somebody was to second
it we'd ever vote then we would see
whether we win or whether we don't and
then if we just refused and you'll have
to give reasons for refusal that's just
the way to move forward
councillor Barnes I believe you were
proposing it weren't you trying to move
it I know you wants to German appears to
be the the the this is really split and
that may be the decision whatever
decision comes due and whereas the
committee we have to agree to Kelso
Crump yeah so just come back to my a
little bit about prematurity and it's
mentioned in the report on page 66 about
the potential offer for it to be
maintained for agriculture
purposes page page 66 6 paragraph about
you know an offer to barn buildings for
for agricultural purposes so an ideal
warranty of it if we could still
maintain is an agricultural building
that would be speculative comment there
was notice the problems that we can't it
is all right there's no there's no
ground there's nothing for us to go on
is that so we I mean yeah let's go to
vote has been proposed and seconded that
we grant the application well I will
start with the first one thought are you
not second again why I need a second of
them now I know right what I will
extremely reluctantly because I just the
one thing I'm very very aware of is
appeal costs on this one as well
we already is five of us here sat
discussing this with going through this
line by line detail by detail and none
of us can find strong evidence that's
going to be proper planning grounds to
refusal therefore we know the scenic
event going to an appeal and we're going
to end up having possibly appeal tossed
against the council we've got to take
into account how strong our reasons
strong reason as Miss Jim its it to my
mind you know it is unsustainable wrong
place understand system in in the middle
of a working
agricultural farm it is just not
workable on to 20 hunts when they think
of it good no I think I agree I like
I've said already I think you're right
but then we look at what the appeal
decision was on the previous one the
previous application very similar to
this we've got the what the the
inspector said the inspector said that
he thinks that the benefit of new
dwelling houses that will preserve that
listed buildings etc outweigh the
unsustainability argument why won't he
say that again of course he will he'll
say it again
oops I'm trying to work out what the
point of us objecting again is based on
that reason unless we have any other
evidence so what are we gonna do if we
can't make a decision we have to go with
the officers so if I don't get a
seconder then it will be refused I'm
also finding difficulty with against the
milk coming up with a very strong
argument Thank You cancer prey which is
about what I was about to do as well so
we have it proposed in second if I feel
that you get to the vote and I say that
very reluctantly what I'm about to do
here so all those in favor of granting
will start the first application please
show or what against and all those in
favor of the listed building consent
again for chairman turn those against
someone against thank you
therefore I think it's fair to say with
great regret the committee results to
grant application reference 17 / 0 0 to
6 1 / fu L + 17 / 0 0 to 6 to 12 / RBC
believe
yes thank you if we'll just take
literally 30-second break
you forget water okay
Oh loss loss counsel okay Richard okay
so let's go to item 8 and we need to get
a move on I think really don't wait sir
this on page 77 this application
reference 17 / 0 1 0 9 9 / lbc in his 36
telegraph street ships Dawnstar
to replace the steel and wooden framed
windows at rear of the property and put
on the first and second floors wooden
frame he goes on a little I think help
and handover to presenting officer
robert park guilted robert over to you
thank you chairman the site is located
within the historic core ship stone and
falls within the conservation area as
identified by the pink line listed
billions are outlined in red the
building concerned is data 1729 and is
listed great - this photo illustrates
the front elevation with four metal
Krita windows under late 20th century
dormer with timber casements the four
metal windows at the front were replaced
in 2016 with mr. beniker sent using a
similar design it is of note that the
fork rattle windows shown here referred
to in the list description but this does
not infer in infirmary architecture or
historically
this photo illustrates the new approved
metal windows which replace the Crito
the the system is similar to critical
but by a different company these windows
have double glazing the frames glazing
bars grace of our sections etc match
those in the critical in the previous
critical windows and this is a close-up
of the new window at the front which
shows how close they are to the the
Crito type the rear is made up of two
modern extensions that on the left with
red brick was built in the 1950s and the
right in the 1990s the window is in each
extension contemporary with the
respective phases the conservatory was
approved in 2006 this is also of the
rear which shows close-up of the rear
dormer which also has a critical type
window and probably dates from the 1950s
the proposals include the substitution
of the existing casements to the front
with a metal type to match those
approved below and to the rear the
proposal includes the substitution of
all the first-floor windows with again
similar types to match those on the
front and the replacement of the dorm up
with the same system all the existing
apart from that on the first floor a
metal the one on the right on the first
floor is timber and again the dormer is
made of metal critical
the proposal again is to copy the
existing subdivision the same sections
etc in the new design and the finish
will be colored white to match the
existing the most significant change
will be that the timber casements in the
front dormer will be changed to metal
with a horizontal glazing bar to match
the pattern in the adjacent dormer as
you can see in this photo the this
casement here in the applicants property
will be made to match the design of the
dormer on the left to provide some sort
of uniformity it is accepted that these
critical windows of 1930s 50s are
unsympathetic to the design of building
but they were there at the time of
listing probably the original
proportions were those on the left which
is the neighboring property which are
much more traditional the existing
caissons they are a Victorian possibly
1860s or slightly earlier
and just to end that Joe is a section of
the existence a section of the windows
the Crito and the section through the
proposed as you can see this very little
change major changes that the windows
will be double glazed to improve heat
insulation but from the outside
it'd be difficult to appreciate and a
changing character thank you chairman
thank you rob okay I'll speak on this
application I think that's just the
applicant please James Hall welcome mr.
Hall sorry to keep you so long tonight
you have three minutes if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end and
I'll give you a warning at ten seconds
if that's okay okay okay okay thank you
my wife and I bought 36 Telegraph Street
about 18 months ago and it's the first
listed property we've owned we fell in
love with it and we don't want to change
it only maintain it and possibly make it
a little warmer my wife will tell you
she's never been as cold as she was last
winter with that in mind earlier this
year after receiving listed building
consent we replaced that metal framed
windows at the front with like-for-like
new windows the only difference being
the change from single to slimline
double-glazed glass there were no
objections to this application which was
at the front of the property the oldest
part of the house holds earth windows
who did installation had done have had a
fabulous job and apart from the fact
that the paint work is no longer chipped
and the windows fit properly you
wouldn't know the originals have been
replaced we now want to finish the job
and do the same at the back of the
property as the owner of the house I can
say that the back of the house is not
pretty it's a mishmash of unattractive
essentially extensions which have been
done over the years the proposals are
similar to that agreed for the front we
want to replace the windows like for
like in the same design as is there at
the moment
that is steel frame windows but with
slimline double glazing in order to had
some harmony to the rear we also propose
to change the one wooden window which
was installed with an extension in the
1990s with the same design of metal
framed window to match the other windows
the insulation value of the new units is
double that of the old windows and once
we can't quote that with these windows
the house will be doubly
energy-efficient due to the fabric of
the rest of the house at least we feel
we are contributing to improving the
house and energy consumption and carbon
footprint we are confused by the
objection to this application having
already replaced the front windows with
listed building consent on the oldest
part of the house and now face the
possibility of not being allowed to
complete the job which will leave our
home unfinished incomplete and obviously
not as energy efficient as we planned
the proposals we're presenting is like
for like and keeps the appearance of the
rear of the house in line with the
listed building status and we see no
architectural value in changing its
appearance it has been suggested to
change the design to smaller window
panes which we have considered however
this would not match the larger pane
windows on the ground floor and would
incur an cost increase of approximately
700 pounds per window which we feel is
not viable thank you thank you very much
any questions please for the applicant
No okay well that's fantastic thank you
very much we go then to our board member
kennix our st.
welcome counselor st. so you have five
minutes over to you
Thank You chairman I I feel a little
between a rock and a hard place on this
one because I don't have the support of
the parish council this evening because
as I recall it
they sat there at their meeting and said
we'll leave this to the experts
well 18 months ago when the replacement
front windows were approved I took that
view we'll leave it to the experts and
they've come up with what I think is
inappropriate for a listed building
however I understand everybody is now in
a dilemma as to what to do because that
was approved and I might draw attention
to the fact that the listing I asked for
refers to listing on the 2nd of
September 1952 whether or not the
original Krita windows were put in
before or after that I do not know and
the planning authority at the time was
shifts and royal district council we
don't have any contact with them the
issue is that there are a number of case
months referred to in the listing and
the casements will of course include
windows I also refer to some
correspondence I had with the case
officer who described the existing
critical windows and he said overall the
pattern is unfortunate and a complete
overhaul with more traditional timber
casements is highly desirable and that
concurred with my view and I think given
a repeat of history I'd have gone back
and said that there should be wooden
windows and wooden double glazing units
are available I've got them throughout
my non-listed house you're free to come
and see them the applicant is free to
come and see them however because I
don't have width then I can understand
them wanting to actually put the
insulation of double glazing in I think
most people would and I would be very
supportive of that however I do believe
quite strongly that we listed buildings
we should be encouraging windows of
timber construction of traditional
design and effectively if that's the
replacement windows I could hardly tell
the difference actually when we when
Robert showed them but beforehand again
are they really the most suitable
however they are there with permission
so I could understand a view that there
is a need to actually have consistency
around the building there is also a view
that as the case officer said to me on
the 9th of June a complete overhaul with
more traditional timber casements is
highly desirable however we don't have
that in we do not have that in front of
us and the issue is I think one for the
committee and I feel a bit between a
rock and hard place I went on the site
visit this afternoon
I apologize for being a little bit late
but I was tied up at a meeting here
first and then council at Cargill
delayed me from did leaving so we'll
blame him but the issue was that that's
the fact I think we have to preserve the
character of our listed buildings and
this variable of fenestration is not by
any means the most appropriate personal
view but my view in protecting the
interests of the local community and
it's in an area has been pointed out
well there's been a lot of listed
buildings and we have to make certain
that that ships in conservation area
most of which is in my
and I'm keen to maintain and preserve
the character offs okay questions I have
just one if that's okay
yeah you mentioned you say that what we
should be doing is try to preserve what
is is there at the moment the
application would you agree seeks to
replicate what is there at the moment we
should therefore preserve what is there
I think what is what you're saying you'd
rather improve upon it rather than just
preserve I think you're right chairman
and I apologize if I've I've misled what
you've interpreted I've misled you and
you've interpreted what I meant to say
thank you thank you okay
any other questions what member know
that case counsel say it thank you very
much right points of clarification what
we want any questions for the officers
counselor fielding
looking at the neighboring houses are we
if we start to go on put in timber-frame
to ask for the timber framing as
councillor Saints asking for is that not
ruining the street scene look of these
of these buildings
I think it's difficult with these sort
of cases because every case is different
as we know a listed building or a star
burns made up of layers of history
they're adapted over time and as they're
adapted we give value to what we inherit
there are some houses that I've Krita
window is an integral part of that
building's history I wouldn't say in
this case the Crito windows are integral
part as I said that the fact that really
they're mentioned in this description
doesn't infer merit it just helps
identify the building and picks out key
features I think on the front if you
tried to change him to timber it's not
going to respond to the bit windows on
the left which are more historic because
the openings are bigger I don't know how
you you would handle it and I'm not
necessarily convinced that timber would
be an improvement to this application
building but to the back it's it's even
more difficult because not we did we're
not dealing with historic elevation
there's nothing there historic merit so
if we look at what preserving what's
interest in the building what we're
trying to protect you what we're trying
to do is probably protect the appearance
from neighbors and context and as I
think we touched on earlier what what
the applicant is trying to preserve the
status quo
I think everyone accepts that we could
improve but it's a matter of cost as we
hear clarification kept councilor
fielding the the front of the building I
can understand is being listed but the
rear of the building is sort of a
mishmash of different styles different
bricks I think we just got to do what
the best we can is issued is just a
point of clarification or debate well
it's a point of clarification because
with that there's different designs of
brickwork
are there going to be problems in trying
to to match or to put in a timber friend
it's a probably a bit of debate sorry
I'm just that's very quickly to confirm
what my understanding of the site is on
the front the only change will be to the
dormer in the roofline there and that
will be to make it a white metal frame
double glazed unit and on the back just
to confirm the appearance would change
almost well negligibly except for the
one window that you're highlighting at
the moment which would lose a crossbar
so other than that essentially the back
would stay as it is right the window
highlighted the the vertical subdivision
would disappear but you'd still have the
horizontal thank you all right debate
council Mills was just in there that
counts of Harry thanks mr. chairman I
think the appellants got a long way to
improve what they have there already and
they they replacing the dormer in the
front it's gonna meet up good some fun
there the back the yes we saw today the
pretty poor state at the moment the the
windows that are there already and he's
replacing once they'd like for like he's
replacing you know very similar what the
same as in the front so in my mind mr.
Chairman I think the aplans got a long
way to to improve what is there so I go
through with the officers recommendation
was chairman Thank You chairman to me
it's an open-and-shut case precedents
already been president has already been
set with the front and I move straight
forward to a proposal to grant do I have
a seconder for that counts the Mills was
into second there there's nobody else
wishing to speak on me on this should we
go to the vote all those in favor of
granting listed building consent
no updates Oh No thank you okay so the
committee therefore results to grant
application reference 17 / 0 1 0 9 9 /
LBC and we can move to item 9 on the
agenda okay item nine minutes found on
page 85 of your agendas tonight this is
application reference 17 / 0 1 2 4 5 /
TPO this is obviously work works very
well
to alter tree preservation orders and
insertion sorts now our primary school
Station Road ship starts now and the
description is to fill T 1 oak and t2
oak the presenting officers at hours
concert over to you thank you chairman
the application site which is denoted by
the black dots in the center of the plan
is located in ship's annonced our the
TTP ode oak trees the subject of this
application are located within the
ship's turn on style primary school
playing fields and are denoted by the
two green circles on the plan the
application is for the proposed felling
of to tpo to oak trees again denoted by
the green circles on the plan the
property of number 5 Greenway cloves
outlined in red on the plan has suffered
structural damage and the agent for the
application states that this has been
caused by the two oak trees outlined in
green supporting information has been
submitted to demonstrate that the trees
are influencing moisture levels below
the foundations of the building the blue
stars on the plan indicate the locations
of the trial pits and bore holes
referred to within the committee report
so just take you through some photos to
see how visible the trees are this slide
shows a number of photos of the two oak
trees taking at various points along
Hartman's Lane to the north of the site
the blue arrows on the photos point
towards the oak tree
whilst the red arrows show that
occasions along to the top site Allman's
Lane where the photos have been taken
this slide shows more photos of the two
trees the viewpoint at number four is
taken from the access Drive adjacent to
the nursery to the north of the site
number five from Brookfield Lane to the
north west of the site and number six
from Darwin's cut road to the southwest
of the site again the blue arrows point
towards the oak trees in question photo
7 shows views of the trees from Greenway
Road and photo eight shows views from
the garden of number five Greenway close
the property suffering structural damage
these photos are taken from Greenway
close and show the trees in 2015 prior
to the 70% crown reduction which took
place following approval from the LPL PA
and in 2017 as now reduced this plan
shows the extension of number five
Greenway close where the trial pits and
bull holes have been carried out as well
as the areas of level monitoring denoted
by these points here here are internal
photos of number five Greenway close the
cracks in the lint or between the
original dwelling and extension can be
seen as can the cracks down the walls
and across the floor and again further
photos taken inside number five Greenway
closed chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to
replacement planting the details of
which to be agreed between the agent
school and local planning authority
thank you thank you alright good our
first speaker counsel Brian Cooper
please from ships and town council
welcome counsel Cooper so you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end thank you very much
and good evening to you all
ships Newtown council takes the view
that any tree subject to the protection
of a preservation order adds value to
the landscape and the community as such
a request for removal is subject to very
careful scrutiny this application
affects two English oak trees within the
grounds of ships tin primary school
both the site investigation report and
the arboriculture assessment report have
indicated that the structural damage
occurring to five Greenway closed is
caused by these trees however with the
closest being approximately 23 metres
from the property this does seem
questionable having said that our
concerns line with the proposed remedial
action the arboriculture assessment
report concludes the pruning the trees
won't provide an effective solution so
it recommends their removal is the
standard response to this type of
problem usually for the benefit of
expediency nowhere within either of the
2 specialist reports is there any
mention of another option specifically
the use of a tree root barrier the
statement of reasons which accompanies
the Arbor a cultural assessment makes a
brief dismissive reference to it we
believe this is a missed opportunity to
be fair location and space constraints
frequently dictate that removal is the
only alternative for example trees
forming a border with another property
or the close proximity of buildings will
have a significant impact on the options
available
quite simply encroachment issues will
generally eliminate a true rip tree root
barrier as an effective solution we
don't have this problem here the trees
are situated within the playing field
area sufficiently distanced from the
boundary of five Greenway close to at
least warrant investigation of this
option it may be that a combination of
actions could be considered for example
cutting back the tree roots followed by
the installation of a tree root barrier
and further pruning of the trees may
offer an alternative to their removal
we don't wish to be obstructive or
unduly delay any structural remedial
work to five Greenway close we'll be
quite prepared to review our position in
the light of any new report that
includes a comprehensive assessment of
all of the options especially the
viability of a tree root barrier
consequently you can make all the tree
huggers in ship stand very happy by
declining this application at least in
its present form until more extensive
investigations have been undertaken
thank you thank you any questions yes
cats are Perry thank you good evening
can you just advise whether the Town
Council has sought or even has as part
of the Parish Council a specialist tree
advisor as a member of the council or
have you sought outside consultancy
advice in coming in being able to come
forward with your objections to this
application
no we haven't we've relied on the
reports that have actually been produced
and in the main we don't object to the
fact that the damage has been caused the
question is identifying the root cause
if we excludes the pun and the proposed
remedial action so we're not questioning
the site investigation record in
deducing that structural damage has been
caused any other questions
good evening um you mentioned tree root
barrier cutting back the tree roots and
pruning of trees was there another
strategy you mentioned I misheard
something anyone know it was it was the
one which was actually raised at the
town council meeting the question of
whether or not we should support the
felling of the trees was discussed but
discounted because of the value that the
Town Council places on trees which are
subject to a tree preservation order
okay with the three strategies to
protect the tree but still address the
the root growth was tree root barrier
cutting back the tree roots and pruning
of the trees yes as I understand it I'm
not an expert this would involve
effectively digging down a deep trench
and play
a physical barrier between the trees and
the property itself but as the
specialist supports of indicated there's
no guarantee of success but we do feel
that as the trees have been there a long
time and add value to our community we
don't necessarily want to give up on
them and it's worth pointing out they're
not diseased the Opera cultural
assessment report Thank You Council
Mills were you indicating look at your
waving at making that case there are no
further questions
yes Oh Cooper thank you very much okay
I'll get our next week capsule Barker
please chair of Governors of the if
substance under our primary school
welcome Council Barkin you only have
three minutes I'm afraid but if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end over T I'm surely some gaps
thank you very much time here my
capacity as chair of Governors of the
ships Turner Federation the governors
are horrified at the prospect of being
told we have to take these trees down
for the Expediency of an insurance
company we're not convinced by the
evidence that we've been given to date
and I would note that in trial pit to
which is shown on there only one
millimeter roots have been found and
they couldn't tell whether it was oak or
sweet chestnut so I'm somewhat concerned
that there is an expectation that
insurance companies can always do this
because it's the expedient thing and
nobody will get in the way and on this
occasion 400 children plus their parents
and the governor's are going to get in
the way and I'm gonna do a swampy if
we're not careful which the local press
are really looking forward to underneath
these trees our school has its forest
school it's about getting the kids
outside doing lesson
out there and they are sheltered by
those trees a point has been made about
number five Greenway close that the
Foundation's should be deep enough and
that regulations dictate that they
should be a deep enough one already but
they're not and I'm not quite sure why
it is we who have to have our trees
removed because somebody didn't put the
foundations in properly anecdotally the
first set of foundations a local builder
told us he was involved in building it
in 1965 and was told to do it fast and
cheap so that's all I'm gonna say about
foundations put on clay near trees that
have been there for several hundred
years beforehand however with my
counselors hat on I know what the upshot
of this is likely to be so in the event
that you grant permission for felling I
want to see the trees replaced like for
like in a different position that is
accepted and indemnified by the insurers
of this property
further indemnifying us against any
costs related to the other trees which
we are not going to remove and that that
is part of the agreement should we reach
a middle ground then as Bryan has said
councillor Cooper has said a tree root
barrier really would be the best option
and there's no likelihood of the school
saying no to this because we've got the
space as you can see between the green
circles in the red square issue thing
what I would ask you to do with my Tara
governor's hat on is to take seriously
the fact that it was this felling
application was made joking during the
period of time where we were taking
environmentalism as our value of what's
it's actually saying to the kids okay
thank you any questions for the chair of
Governors know that case thank you
we go to our ward member again
councillor st. welcome back Thank You
chairman over to you before I'm asked
the question I'm not an expert okay go
for it
however I am accounts of many years
experience and they'll have been to
countless planning training sessions
over the years and indeed feel that I
know when right is on our side and I
don't think the proposal here is right
on our side and I think the critical
thing is and I do have an ancestry in
the building trade so I might have a
little bit of a whatever you call it in
my blood I'm looking at page 91 it
refers to crack monitoring has been
undertaken in the building the area
where the original building meets the
extension and it seems to me the problem
occurs at that juncture between the
original bungalow dwelling and the
extension I'm not going to pass judgment
on Joe Barker's comments about
instructions given to the original
builder but however what I am going to
say is that that is a significant issue
damage appears to occurred where an
extension has met and originally
presumably well-constructed
well-designed building and if that
juncture was not created as if it was
part of a coherent original building I
think that's a significant issue I agree
with councillor Cooper from the Town
Council but effectively if these trees
are a problem then there should be some
underground protection but given the
distance of these oak trees from the
bill
with this extension I'm surprised evoke
roots would have gone out that farm oak
roots don't spread they go down and I'm
not an arboreal culturalist either but
please believe me that I have learned
that much in my life up to now so
consequently as I think has already been
mentioned the actual sort of capillary
roots that may well have crept towards
this extension may be overplayed in the
claim to want these things cut down my
other feature is this if these trees
were listed and I accept that they've
been hacked about unnecessarily before I
was the war member for this particular
part of the world don't forget I
acquired this only two years ago when
the boundary changes came in if both
trees had effectively been listed well
prior to that there must have been a
good reason and there is nothing in this
application all the proposals that
actually gives me any comfort to support
their removal because the listing was
put there for a reason
not even the incredible haircut that
they were granting which I hope is
recovered as soon as possible as soon as
growth is allowed therefore I strongly
urge the committee to take seriously
these points from amateurs but
effectively there is good reason one is
it's where annex the damage is where an
extension meets the building so it might
be unfair to blame the tree secondly if
they were listed in the first place
there was good reason to list them right
and thirdly there are other solutions if
indeed the arboriculture all this works
around the school playing field are
indeed going to be culpable of the blame
okay questions council Perry good
evening counselor st. I just wondered
whether you would like to comment on an
aspect to the officers report that
highlights to refuse consent to fell the
trees would result in a compensation
claim to the local planning authority in
the region of 70,000 pounds would you
like to comment on that yes I still
believe that the trees are worth
protecting
right I don't wish to waste the
councillors money as the custodian of
the budget most of the time I'm fully
aware of this but effectively that could
be an exaggerated claim it's planning by
fear and I think we have to maintain the
character of our community
and also I think it's pretty councillor
bar president here because she and I
have discussed this in the past and I
think there is a good case that the
schools insurers would actually meet a
lot of those costs
nobody whatever convinced me that any
financial risk is a threat to good
planning premature principles being
displayed council bonds I can ask this
question mr. chairman I'm sure we have
stock me everyone
my thoughts are that we need a third
party to come and leave you join us I
don't think the oak trees would myself
personally but if we would have
suspended the application and for a
third party to look at the effect would
yet would you support that not my
decision chairman is it right it's a
little bit academic I think the rules
require us to take the officer's advice
to listen to representations in a
democratic way I am form a decision
question though is would you would you
support a deferral in
in order to look at further evidence is
there any further evidence you think
that would be required to help with this
decision I think I think I think you've
had three people here to present you all
with contrasting evidence but evidence
to these complimentary to each other and
and therefore yeah any other questions
nope
counsel say thank you right
should we go two points of clarification
Kent's like Mills thanks mr. chairman
can someone tell me when this extension
was built many
the exemption to the northwestern
elevation which is obviously this one
here was constructed in 1998 thanks but
if I may ask her another question at U
of Ruth how old are these trees between
hundred and twenty thousand and fifty
one hundred twenty hundred and fifty and
the going back to the officers and the
when worthy is with original buildings
built what 1965 60 k thank you so
Building Council fielding to chill three
things one is that I used to look after
a lot of woodland and forestry many
moons ago the normal rule of thumb was
the canopy of an oak tree was basically
the width of the roots that were
underneath it they didn't really extend
much beyond that there was a image that
came up showing I think the cracking in
the corners you've gone a bit too far
fast can you go back slowly decaying
there they are the that shows the
extension where the where the cracking
is where is the trees in line where are
the trees on that image so there the
other side of the building from the
trees that surely is very much in line
with foundation movement because if the
roots were going in underneath there
they would affect the other side of the
building has the building on the
neighboring house has that been affected
with any form of substance
joining property unfortunately so we
can't confirm that I'm just going to ask
a question and maybe Richard or may say
whoever wants to answer this I'm very
concerned we're getting way off topic in
looking at the damage to the house and
all of this can I be clear and
incredibly from wrong because we don't
deal with TPS very often at the
committee but if we grant this
application the school are not bound in
any way to fail these trees they could
effectively the school can continue to
find resolution with the people that let
the courtyards currently they can do
that themselves all we're doing is
saying yes if you want to if that's the
decision you as other individuals
country you can fill the trays we're not
saying you have to fill the trees yes
that's right I'll stand to be corrected
by the solicitor in the room but my
understanding is if you grant this
tonight the trees then are no longer at
APO they just become normal trees
they're the property of the school and
to take them down
would need to join in property and if I
didn't sell it the loss of justice would
have it by Ann Arbor called forest yes
well I'll go back to the point and I've
mentioned many times on highway matters
about ignoring reports we've got one
expert report and basically no others so
the committee should be very worried
about ignoring or dismissing the report
that's been forwarded to us I'm just
gonna carry on force it and I just want
to confirm what I'm saying so if we were
to grant this application tonight the
school do not have to follow and fell
these trees at all that will be for them
to decide what their best course of
action is and you've just made sure that
we have
our due diligence is the local authority
am i correct yes
okay you are correct yes it'll be a
matter between the insurers and then the
school process it's a matter of
absorbing ourselves from any liability
or negligence everybody's indicated in
the order counselor bouncing counts of
hiring the Middle's when I was going
from when I spoke to Kansas I really was
that in my personal opinion I don't
think the trees are a problem justice
but that's a personal thing I do know a
bit about mister points of California is
that I think a second opinion which the
school could take on whether to take
them down or not so as far as I'm
concerned they should stay clarification
if that's okay so any questions to the
officers I know I'm taking a bit out of
order but counts Lipari Thank You chair
the council is very fortunate to have
someone with such great expertise as
Ruth Rose who knows has has extensive
experience so my question to your Rose
is has have we had a sort of a similar
case to this coming forward to the
council before generally speaking the
they don't come forward to committee
because we normally resolve them and
because we have issues with compensation
claims coming in if we refused such
items generally speaking we don't raise
objection to them and it's a stance
we've taken now for about six or seven
years that we do it place trees on your
protection retreat preservation order if
they're already causing damage and if
they are already causing damage then
obviously we have to look at the
evidence is submitted
and make a decision on that can I come
back with a supplementary is is the
recommendation for this particular
application particularly driven by
the threat is a compensation claim I
think it's both it's part of the
application process I have to look at
certain factors which obviously is
includes the immediate value of the
trees but I also have to consider
whether there's going to be any loss or
damage lately to arise if consent is
refused or granted for the application
so I have to take into consideration
what damage could occur it's something
we have to do
sorry chair can I just come back with
one more are you 100% happy with the
report that was presented and undertaken
by the experts and in your professional
experience I think on this occasion
we've actually got monitoring the
records which go back from October 19
2013 so we've actually got quite a large
expanse that we can look at to see
what's going on with the tree and the
movement of the building generally
speaking really insurers only have to
show us that there are seasonal movement
happening to whether that's between
spring and summer or summer than autumn
and that is enough evidence for us to
accept that the trees are having an
influence over the building as you see
in this case we've got far more
information that we've been normally
have and we also have level monitoring
of the building as well as crack
monitoring so they've wanted to with the
crack opening and closing over the years
over the months and we also have level
monitoring where they've actually wanted
the level in the building at certain
points and that sure was there it
actually drops in the summer months and
the rises again in the optimal winter
more into the winter when the soil
rehydrates councils thanks miss general
just just make clear on my mind there
are no cracks appearing anywhere else in
the house it's just this new extension
it's not there are a number of practices
of all outside the building certainly on
northern wall but certainly internally
that's the main area of concern and that
that extension is where all the test
Wars and the pits were undertaken to see
if the routes were under that area thank
you and just really for Mesa
if the tpo were to be removed then but
does this become a civil matter between
the school and the residence of none of
mine yes it does simple as that
yes okay thank God number of people
still in good accounts the brain then
counts of fielding than councilor Trump
from my limited experience chairman I
think oak trees are very shallow roots
mistaken but I heard what the Parish
Council said and I have the experience
of having a foundation put in between
trees and buildings where did to stop
the root structure it is a possibility
it would have to be on the skill ground
so it wouldn't be under the control of
the property that's having issues the
insurers may well have problems with
that because it is on third party round
it would have to you on the skill ground
because there's simply not enough room
between the back of the building and the
actual boundary however also there's
plenty of room between the trees and the
actual property it is a possibility
however the property insurers would have
to come to some sort of agreement with
the school insurers I would suggest to
see that it's going to be acceptable
okay cancel building what you're
describing is a typical problem with
clay in itself is it expands depending
on the moisture content of it the trees
are on the further side from where the
cracking is taking place surely if it
was the roots that were doing that the
other side of the house near as the
trees would be affected
I think standardly corrected by Ruth but
I think it's not the actual physical
action of the roots it's what they're
doing to the soil generally so I think
the effect they're having is quite
widespread and the building is moving as
one as a result so the the traits as it
were the impacts can be seen across the
building perhaps not just in the closest
part to where the roots come cats
crumble I'm just looking at page 93
whereas I think in the fact in effect
we've this is an allowing the previous
reduction work to proceed the local
planning authority came to the
conclusion that the trees were
influencing the movement within the
property and that there was
justification to a low socio duction
work to proceed so basically haven't we
already admitted or haven't we already
come to the conclusion that it was the
trees causing this clarification debate
who would like to start council Mills
your heart tells you that you didn't
want these trees locked down I certainly
wouldn't want them taken down they were
there hundred and twenty years before
the houses are built and you think
perhaps a builder sure thought about
this and that's bill - when the
extension should have thought about that
as well but then we've got the experts
telling us there is a problem gosh I
don't know
my heart tells me that we shouldn't take
it down mr. Chanin but the brain tells
me you didn't tell me anything in a
moment
but a bit empty computers too kind to
mr. chair Thank You counsel brain
difficult application I'm very
passionate about trees just oak trees in
general 150 meter to the school yeah we
have evidence a causing problems we've
decided that's conclusive evidence it's
not we've been told it is conclusive yes
we're done I think this is tricky one
and it's about balance isn't it I don't
think you should form a judgment in fear
of a compensation claim and I think
there are alternatives that are an offer
we could preserve the trees the tree
root barrier I think is great a great
idea then it is obviously negotiating
with it being on the third party ground
and the cutting back of the tree or it's
the pruning of the trees I think there
are other steps that can take place
before you throw away 120 years of tree
history in the same position as the last
speaker I think we should allow the
school to decide what's happening with
the school the church okay right a
minute the trees and not the building
and remedial action I find could be
taken we've had some listed buildings
over the time where trees have been
closed and builders have suggested
piling and various other things and also
they there is a way of restricting the
root growth to certain directions so I
think myself that they shouldn't come
down I think we should be left to the
school till decide what to do and how to
do it in the appropriate manner you know
people want I'm going to put my ideas in
first if that's okay I completely agree
with you it should be for the school to
decide they own the trees it's up to
them
we've accepted already that we have
adequate evidence that the trees
although unusual the trees are causing
some damage to the house we accept that
so something needs to be done about the
trees we've accepted that there are a
series of options there are route
barriers that could be put in felling is
another option there are a series of
different options the school should be
working with these residents in the
bungalow here to decide what is best and
it is to the school to decide that now
that's not for this committee to start
to decide tonight what this committee to
decide tonight is whether or not we give
them the option of felling should the
school decide to do that but it is for
the school to decide all we're doing is
putting the paperwork in place for them
to take those trees down if they decide
that's what they want to do we are not
giving permission we're not sending him
you know people with chainsaws tomorrow
to cut these down we're saying it by
granting this if that is this big teach
the course the school want to take then
that's fine we've got evidence to say of
those damage being caused that is all
we're being asked to do we're not being
asked to chop the trees down ourselves
counts our brain our trees we're not
given permission to take the TPO away
which would be a different matter who
removes the tpo then it would be a
matter for the school we're given
permission to fire the trees have to ask
them it mazey can you confirm this am i
right or not i need somebody to confirm
whether I'm wrong if I'm wrong please
tell me we are given permission to
actually fell the trees but it's a third
party and the third party can't felled
the trees it would have to be the school
unless the insurers actually brought a
case against the school which allowed
them to go in and fold the trees that's
the way my interpretation goes so again
for the school to settle not for us
right I'm gonna try and get that to pee
I'm sorry I interrupted so I've got a
flow people I've got councillor Perry
then councillor fielding the council
abound thank you thank you chair might
be concern about this is that if we go
with the officers recommendation
we are weakening the situation with the
insurers because then they will use that
too but I just I just feel it it weakens
weakens the whole case I think the most
important thing is Stratford district
council strap the district is a rural
community it is a roar it is one of
England's most rural districts one of
the characters of stratford-on-avon
district is the fact that we have
significant beautiful oak trees we have
a number of other specimen trees and I
think we owe it to ship stone and the
school to do everything that we can to
protect the character and the
environment of that particular area
thing between the insurance and the
school I believe that if there was a
real case for the trees other properties
would be affected we would have had
other cases coming forward I've also
seen the effect of oak roots lifting up
something like that path and damaging it
that I don't know whether that has we
haven't been told about that but I think
it's more I think more information
should be given and I think it's really
between the school and the property I
think we should leave it to the school I
think what you said in your button you
know whatever you like to call it is
correct so therefore if we go along with
the officers recommendation still made
the truth trees can be saved but it
won't be our responsibility but nobody
wants to cut trees down there's a
probably a third of their life you know
less than 20% of their life but I think
we're in a situation where we leave it
to the school to make a remedy if and I
think the word is
if we agree or don't agree with a
professional and whether these cracks
are caused by the tree because I don't
think of that distance others raised yes
but not oak trees cats are a gentleman I
wonder if there's a a reason for a
deferral here and to send them away to
look at the case for mitigation you've
heard the conservation officer or the
tree will say there is a possibility of
putting a foundation in to stop the root
structure going any further and I wonder
if it's a case for a deferral to let
that work to happen then I'll grow
propose that if I got a seconder we have
a secondary second
right capsule Milt you indicated sorry
thanks miss chim let's say we the
committee went against the officers
recommendation then does this put the
onus on us then things with toes up
think better phrase yes as he as advice
before yes it could do like I mentioned
before about highways cases if the
county object to something and we
dismiss their objection that we could be
liable it's it's the same principle
counsel Mills we have an expert report
and if we dismiss that we could be
liable thank mr. chairman can you get
there something the audience type
talking it reduces track - mica - yeah
thank you
I don't know who it is I'm not looking
that way but annoying me I offer a
deferral and I don't think that puts it
in a weakened position at all it's just
the last time for an answer to combat
negative or positive damn it if you can
be mitigated or not you spective there
is an issue of liability and I would
love the committee to absolve themselves
on this and leave it to the school and
insurers but it's their decision to make
and if they want to defer maybe we can
assess it okay Ruth wants to come in
then I'm gonna go - you can't Sabri I
mean I've raised the issue of the
possibility of a root barrier with the
agents and again they have said it
really that is an issue that it would
have to be undertaken agreed between the
school insurers and the property
insurers we have the proposal table to
fill the trees and that really is
I think we can comment on I just don't
think a month or a couple of months is
going to make a lot of difference here
if we've covered the ground to find out
if there is a scheme and mitigation if
not if not and it's back with us to make
that decision with you which is not
going to make much difference is it Ruth
I would suggest that the applicants will
go straight to appeal well my view is
definitely I think this is an issue for
the school and for the residents here to
do settle between them I'm not sure what
will achieve by deferring it but
nevertheless deferment has been proposed
and seconded should we take a vote on
that all those in favor of deferring
this so it can get more information on
other options please show six Chairman
those against deferment tutor all right
just be clear misty on what options they
committee would like explored in this
deferment period understand it is it for
a route protection zone to be put in
place they'll ask ask the proposal in
the deferment period now what options
would committee dark explore presume
history protection trench to be put in
okay fair enough in that case the
committee results to defer gauging
reference 17 / 0 1 2 4 5 / TPO to a
later date item 10 on tonight's agenda
is found on page 97 No you've got three
more to go
not far oh yes we need to vote that way
do we need to vote on continuing
we're okay we can continue for one
though okay what to tell you all right
okay so this is application reference 16
/ 0 2 4 7 9 / ful this hillside Clinton
Road Gaiden and it's for the
construction of one new detached
dwelling the presenting officers and
ekata handing over to you thank you
chair
sorry about the slight pause all I hear
get in the seat here's the overall
contact plan with the site indicated by
a black dot and the site there is
outlined in red forming part of the
building line of Canton Road that's the
site layout plan it's a single detached
dwelling the parking to the front the
access road that exists to the north top
of the page which is in fact the north
of the red line affords access to the
rear of the site for an existing
dwelling that's from elevation of the
proposed the typical dormer windows does
result in a partial flat roof owing to
the square plot or a square footprint of
the house these are the two side
elevations with no fenestration to
attempt to ensure no overlooking of
neighboring properties and here the
floor plans you can see at the top there
the flat roofs I referred to earlier
integral garage and can square footprint
achieving three bedrooms not some
photographs this is taken from kind of
Road it wasn't planned
for hours choose postponed couldn't
resist that one so yeah as I was saying
the site is that rather large vegetative
mass with the access road on the
left-hand side of the photo there which
affords access to the plotter dwellings
at the rear that's within the site this
photo graphic shows two construction
cabins that are on the on the site
scientist rather a kind of overgrown
feel to it I'm not sure how long the
construction cabins have been there but
they're quite well established and these
photographs now are of dwelling approved
under a 2013 application which you can
see the reference there dwelling to the
front of the picture is to be demolished
and then leaving a single dwelling which
is the dwelling on the rear of the the
shop which is rather modern flat roof
structure I put those up for context
they're not within the application plot
but they do sit to the land at the rear
and then a bit more context this is one
adjacent property to the to the site and
that is the other immediately north east
there's the rear elevation of the
proposed property the recommendation is
to grant there's been warm update which
is in the update sheet and I think is
appended to the update sheet which
hopefully you've got in your papers
thank you thank you Andy
right our first speaker is counselor Ian
Claxton again yeah it's like thank you
hanging around
sorry it's long it was one short over to
you
Gate and parish council objects this
application on two counts
firstly the conditions of the previous
application she's been all be mentioned
from 2013 on the site have not been met
in the four years since is granted
namely the demolition of the second
dwelling the first original dwelling the
reason stated I believe in the
application for the demolition was to
ensure that only one dwelling was on the
site in accord with local plan policy
I'll leave
carefully Kendall to expand on it and
the second point is that pursuant to the
core strategy and as clearly detailed
and council kettle's documents and the
amendments additions to the attached
here with the gaiden parish has not only
met but comfortably exceeding it's
housing housing requirement they've
quoted therefore feel that is this
application exceeds exceeds the limit
the right percent of the 400 houses
follow the same policy CS 16 and
therefore does not comply with cs50 nor
a s 10 further does not meet the local
need guidelines I set out in a s-10 with
apologies to the applicant unless a
stake is put into the ground the limits
set out in the various strategies are
worthless
thank you cancel any questions for
parish council councillor fielding can I
ask you to press the microphone identify
the site the carts and Road is to the
far right yeah
you've got site which is red and then
you've got the area at the back there is
that where the exact house that is being
built is is situated that that's where
the arrow is is is the new construction
I know what is in the red there is
nothing there at the moment it's it's
all part of the same property there was
nothing there if you drive past the
gravel there the gravel area now if you
drive past it all you'll see is this is
the as indicated in one of the
photographs just the edge and the gravel
drive it's not it's not very well
visible from that kiss Council Claxton
thank you very much okay Alistair
Hotchkiss please
good evening thank you for hanging
around again so you have three minutes
if you remain seated for any questions
at the end okay mr. chairman I'm
Alistair Hotchkiss I live in Emily chase
which you can cease immediately to the
north east of the plot I think it's very
important first of all to make clear
that hillside is the full hell l-shaped
plot we shouldn't consider in my view
the red area as a plot on its own the
plot is the whole l-shaped area that
goes beside my property and behind my
property it's very clear that we
understand that I'm not going to spend
too long I hope I won't take the full
three minutes because today what has
been said by Adrienne Claxton is the
perfect summary we're looking here at I
believe a significant over development
and how many of the plot but also of
gayden village I would refer just to
emphasize the planning application and
conditions that were granted in 2013 but
one dwelling and one dwelling only
should remain on the plot and I
emphasized the plot because it is that
whole l-shaped area not just the red
area and therefore as that was a
condition in 2013 I don't understand why
anything would have changed in 2017 I
think it's important to emphasize that
that area is not a vacant plot as I've
heard the expression used it was when I
bought the property family chase about
12 years ago that was an area laid two
lon it was planted the garden of the
hillside property it has now become very
overgrown but it is part of the garden
of the existing property and as has
already been mentioned we as gayden have
already met our planning requirement and
to allow this would seem to be further
over development what is already a
significantly developed village and in
my view changes the character of that
village significantly so I would urge
the committee to reject this application
Thank You mr. chairman
thank you any questions please mr.
Hodges okay thank you very much taking
your time we can go then to the
applicants and the architects please
mr. Sonny dev and mr. Lyle please
welcome John can I ask which is which
Ram beer Sonny thank you so you have six
minutes between you
how'd you want to divide the scene as
well start and then I'll pass the baton
over that's okay okay thank you right
okay so good evening all I'll try and be
the first as possible on it we all want
to get home today I want to start by
saying that I'm here today really for
her this planning application to be
considered for an affordable house to be
built on a viable piece of land that I
own I'm going to spend a minute just
trying to deal with the objections that
I've been raised because I think that's
quite important the first is regarding
this clause that's been raised for a
number of people already today I think
it's important previous application was
for a replacement dwelling of course if
permission was given for that
replacement dwelling which it was then
it's not a surprise that there would be
a clause to say that the existing
dwelling which was on that site would be
demolished therefore leaving only one on
the site it's logical to me that is
something that's going to be fully a
deity you've seen the pictures by the
planning officer that's been put up
that's going to be demolished and if
it's not demolished then I will face the
full wrath of the law and the
enforcement officer I've never indicated
or given any sort of indication that
that would be demolished I think there's
been insinuations that I want in fact I
can confirm it's been demolished on
August the 29th so have this committee
meeting be in four weeks time that
probably wouldn't be there and so I just
wanted to clarify that first of all in
terms of this clause that clause was
very specific to the previous
application that was made and this is a
separate application and should be
judged on its own merits in my opinion
it's for a separate it's it's a plot and
it's a separate site on that plot that
this application is for and I think
they've been some confusion where the
two have been intertwined and confused
into one the other issue is that we've
really come aboard on this project here
in the spirit of compromise we'd really
have worked with the planners change the
designs many times just to appease
everybody we're really not
trying to force this through in any way
or form and we're happy to compromise in
any way that we possibly have been able
to do and so I'll just conclude by
stating how I started really that is all
I want to do is really build an
affordable family house on a plot of
land that I own I'm really finding it
difficult to find the real burdens with
regard to this application in light of
the very tangible benefits that this
house could provide someone we have in
the spirit of compromise put forward
this application hope you look forward
towards it positively signed after
ambien I could evening I just going to
make a couple of points actually um just
to reiterate what Sonny said um the the
proposed site and kind of stitches in
all the kind of the footprint stitches
into the urban kind of grain of that of
that kind of area and of coins and Road
in terms of the kind of development the
actual site if you were to kind of take
the whole of that site as a big al shape
is about three thousand three thousand
three hundred square meters the site
which is red is five hundred five
hundred and thirty square meters the
footprint of the dwelling on the red
kind of outline site is a is 120 square
meters so the actual percentage use is
about 22 percent on that site and so
they actually isn't really any
overdevelopment on that and there is
that clause which is you know the
replacement Dorling so as Sonny is quite
clearly said that that Valley is going
to be implemented and that house will be
demolished and once they occupy that
house of the rear the the you know the
the the proposed dwelling is of a small
scale it offers a variety of typology
with engaging them and the typology is
engaged in are four to five bedroom this
is a three-bedroom dwelling so it kind
of offers a different type of client and
I think the the final thing is that we
have tried to try we've tried to stitch
into the vernacular of gayden as well
with the kind of dormer windows the kind
of core coins around the kind of the
elevations and keeping it quite low-key
and kind of stitching into that whole
area thank you thank you any questions
please yes counselor Crump
I'm live in the report there's been 24
that's his objection some of which were
duplicated and obviously the parish
council is objecting did you get to
speak to the parish council to discuss
your position and worry about her you
know I have to lay my cards on the table
actually didn't maybe have kind of
cynical view of this but I knew there
was going to be objections people don't
like change that's a natural reaction
parish councils would generally go with
the majority of the people with
hindsight I wish I had I've got to admit
I'm sitting here today thinking well
actually that was probably a mistake on
my side but I still think would be here
today had I done that these same
arguments having these same discussions
today you know all we're trying to do is
really not trying to offend anybody at
all which is what I try to say in my
statement was we are trying to appease
everybody here not trying to break the
wheel rebuild it you would have gotten
to speak from councillor Fielding are
you looking to do it as an affordable
home therefore done with the support of
the Housing Association or are you
looking to do it as affordable community
home which is for the benefit of the
parish just it just isn't affordable
homes or something can I confirm it as
an open market dwelling it's not we
would consider an affordable home sorry
yes it's not okay thank you any other
questions that case gentlemen thank you
very much thank you right
okay accounts cattle what member yeah
welcome castle you have five minutes
over to you has just heard
there has been no discussion with the
board member always at the parish
council this player already has one
substantial new dwelling built on it you
can see the photograph but an improving
it this council includes the condition
the existing dwelling known as hillside
shall be demolished and materials to
move from the site reason to ensure
there's only one dwelling on this site
this condition was imposed in 2013
comply with the MPP F and although the
local planners superseded the relevant
policies have been replaced by policies
CS 15 and Ayers ten why is the council
now seeking to override its previous
decision by allowing a second dwelling
on this site I Kristen were the highways
of prudence in allowing another driveway
in such a close proximity to the
existing hillside and other adjacent
dries including Amelie close second
picture I have concerns on the
requirement for good design
cs9 when this house is being squeezed
into a very small patch unlike the other
spacious thoughts on both sides of the
Kyneton road picture three and secondly
as described an austere report with no
windows on either side to prevent
overlooking would you want to live in
this house
finally planning precipitations must be
considered and determined in line with
the core strategy we ignore our core
strategy so soon after its doctrine last
year to our parent consider policies CS
15 CS 16 and a s 10 the author has said
this application complies with sales 15
and heirs 10 but not with CS 16 however
this cannot be correct than through
policies that inextricably linked the
core strategy states to comply with CS
15 and a s 10 an application must comply
with CS 16 I quote s 10 page 192 schemes
in
fees are acceptable if in accordance
with policies CS 15 and CS 16 and CS 15
the scale of development the housing
government thus appropriate in each
village is specified in policy CS 16
concrete what the report says if an
application does not comply CS 16 it
cannot comply with a s10 and cs50 the
officer confirms that the application is
not comply the CS 16 his justification
seems Bend on the basis that the
category four villages should have
approximately 8% of the 400 total for
careful villages 8 percent of 400 is 32
houses are not the 44 that Kappa Gaiden
will have adopted a 34% increase in our
allocated number further development
management considerations Cesare's 15 in
the core strategy state that the housing
grants for each category of LS fees
represent what the council considers to
be appropriate however these crumbs do
not prevent a particular community from
delivering additional development if it
considers appropriate and supported
through a local needs scheme there is no
identified local need piece of through
the planning inspector reporting on the
core strategy said in view of my view
the list of villages is a reasonable
basis on which of direct the 2000 well
is currently proposed in order to
achieve a sustainable outcome and noting
that the number of dwellings allocated
to L as fees has increased in 1950 2000
I consider that the council would need
to robustly justify any further increase
the planning officer has given no robust
justification for this increase in
kuntum and Gaiden from 32 to 44
dwellings mr. drew identified the LS LS
aviv dwelling storage already achieved
99 percent of their 2000 target when he
wrote his report he did not propose that
the LS v number should be increased as
the pairing Planning Oster's now
praising drew continues increasing the
quantum of Housing and the NS fees would
not be the most sustainable option and
revisions to CS 16 to avert the number
of dwellings need sustainable okay
as a minimum are unjustified the
existing approach is justified because
gives all interest parties some
indication of what scale of development
anticipated a s10 does not say
specifically for market led schemes that
are not quite a meat fruit improving
local meat this has been taken from the
development management considerations
which mr. drew has said it's not policy
there should not add or set requirements
to policy if we're going to approve
develops in line with the core strategy
this application is already 34 percent
above its allocated number has to be
refused on policy grounds alone let
alone over develop the site the poor
design of the dwelling on a small plot
and out of contrast with its neighbors
and the multiple driveways that you will
see here coming out onto Canton Road in
close very close proximity to as I set
out and photograph - yes counselor Perry
good evening Council
can you just advise when gayden last did
its housing needs survey and whether it
identified any particular requirement
okay I gave that moment is going through
the process of considering how
developers in a neighborhood plan and
however what you should be aware is that
kind tomb is located I'm sorry Canton
Road gate has worked with two separate
developers to approve 215 house
developments in the village witching
which I believe does include so we've
got affordable housing and we've got 30
houses which are currently being in the
proposed been approved some have been
built somewhere about there built there
is a significant over in the village
thank you so Crump just moving on from
that
was this in an area also I should've
asked to be parsed canceled so sorry but
you're probably now against the kettle
anyway it's just in an area that the
game parish cats will want to be built
in is that in the narrative this
development this property in an area
chosen by Gaiden Parish Council to be
built in know the two Gaiden has already
identified two sites one of which is on
the other side of the road between the
old gate and in pub and the back of the
house is just behind my left wing mirror
on the other side of the road that is
one site that's being developed and the
other one is further out towards Clinton
where there has been a field behind some
affordable houses which has been
developed the considers this is a second
application the previous owners were
talking this site the village has always
felt who have got a consistent and
knowledge roses in big gardens but this
is good thank you I think you've
answered the question is this an area
they want to be built to cancer cancer
that way as well okay don't work that's
okay that's fine any other questions for
the board member know that case
counselor kettle thank you very much
okay Oh on to post clarification capsule
bonds
well clarification really on the core
strategy I've got a couple of villages
that are over their limit will advise
over the two thousand was only a guide
single developments can be allowed and
have been allowed that is the
he's allowed over the limit in different
locations
am i correct but that's what I've been
told consistently just the first point
of clarification is that there's no
upper limits in any of the numbers in
the core strategy what we have are three
levels at the top we've got a level
under CS 16 where the district's overall
has to provide 14,600 additional homes
at least so that's the first level the
next level is for the LSPs overall which
is 2,000 that's approximately so now
I'll put although a limit it's
approximate and that's a matter of
planning judgment when you are no longer
at approximately 2,000 homes and finally
for LSP force of which gaiden is one of
them the term is no more than a round
eight percent so we've got three
different terms there all of that which
needed exercise of planning judgment but
in this case Gaiden where it currently
is is actually roughly around 11% so
it's a matter of planning judgment as to
whether 11 percent is no more than
around 8 percent and if this committee
was to decide well you know that will be
our sole reason our sole reason for
refusal on this what do you think it
would be a very difficult case to make
in the context of the MPF seeking to
significantly boost housing supply and
an overall requirement for the district
that says at least I'm not saying it's
impossible but it would be a very hard
case to make it's not one that's been
right other points of clarification yes
counselor O'Donnell on councilor Perry
can you scan a flow where the affordable
housing element of this is it's not
affordable housing isn't it's just as a
cheaper home okay because it seems a
fillet with the month isn't it
affordable I think the term
affordability has crept in because of
its size you
be more affordable than other dwellings
in the area but it has nothing to secure
its price but you know through a
registered social landlord or whatever
that may be sort of PR Thank You chair
it's the width of this particular plot
but I would like some clarification on
looking at the width of the other
adjacent plots my I'm just I'm just
concerned about the size of the dwelling
being squeezed into that can you just
give some clarification I'm really and
presumably it's part of the ribbon
effect it would be in line with that or
as I say it's my concern I just like
some clarification over the width how
close is it to the boundaries how closes
into neighboring residences yeah okay
well I will tell you the width of plot
hopefully it's a scale of 150 which is
there's not a standard scale at a 3 as
an estimation I would say we're looking
at about a 15 meter wide plot which as I
think the plan there on screen shows is
narrower than any other plot on kinda
Road I don't know the width of the other
plot look just making a judgement of
vision the the widths of the plots to
the to the south southwest or comparable
those to the Northeast or significantly
larger those on the other side of the
road also significantly larger but a 15
meter wide plot is not unusual to
accommodate a single dwelling can I also
what's the width of the house then
the width of the house is 13 meters okay
yes Fabray depending on where imaginary
because it's wider at the top than it is
at the bottom where we sit measured at
the bottom or at the top the measurement
i tilt was at the midpoint which was
could you take it at the bottom and at
the top then I certainly can
so we're tapering down to about 14
meters at the the road frontage and
coming up to about sixteen sixteen point
five at the back of the plot that's not
including the access because that's
outside of the the red line thank you
any of the points of clarification I've
been trying to get my head round it's
11:00 the night per centum and whatever
and the significance between 32 and 43
and where the five-year land supply
which is now at six point seven five
what whirring wait that carries the way
obviously having a five year land land
supply means that you can rely on your
core strategy that keeps it up to date
so that that's important but the other
thing you need to bear in mind is
there's a windfall element within the
numbers in that each one on its own
doesn't contribute much but overall they
do contribute and that needs to be kept
ticking over during the plan period and
I would say this is a windfall site but
I'm afraid I'm still going to offer any
more advice I'm not comfortable myself
with the wording that says no more than
around I couldn't say why it doesn't say
approximate but that's what week that's
the plan we work with and the judgment
is whether eleven
I'll say with me bond and Saturn
obviously going from single figures to
before this room for my percent to 11
percent and obviously the IE percent is
the 32 and 11 percent is the 44 if we
grew they give the approval on it which
is points about win for sites as well
but when there's a win for site more
beneficial to the local plan then it is
to the local community and with this
case yes has been some duplication the
objections but the ward member has been
quite oblivious about this one the PI's
cancel there's been six int but again
objected that we've had a and neighbor
object and we've had 24 with some
duplications so that doesn't seem to be
the support of the local community was
if that local community had been
supportive of this application it was in
the area that they wanted it to be built
in I think it would have had walk
reading it's a more weight and this is
why I think the applicant should have
perhaps to address those issues by
speaking to the parish councils for
themselves so I think that again from my
point years of the development of the
site again is it is the design contrived
again from top middle or bottom from up
to 16 meters and is it in keeping with
the local they're called vernacular
vocal landscapes their vocal streets and
so I'm not particularly happy with this
one band
but as I said earlier really I've got a
lot of villages and might live them on
where we have single developments and
that they've gone through on appeal
we've had to fight the other week to get
one refused but we lost the only way
that this can be refused is the design
and the respect that it's not in keeping
with the other development attached to
it I would like us to refuse this
application because if we did win it
appeal then I could use it myself in my
villages but the situation is that we
are all bent the government in building
houses but I don't think this design I'm
personally crammed in there is in
keeping with the houses that are in the
Pacific see but you can see across the
road or next to them or up across the
road or the one that the gentleman lives
in and that as far as I can see is the
only reason only possible reason that
the numbers are irrelevant
the percentage east appears to be
relevant long masculine should have 33
he's got 88 yeah right
so as far as I'm concerned I'm quite
happy to propose refusal on the
respective it isn't in keeping with the
adjoining and adjacent properties
Calipari well it's a bit of a mirror
image to my colleague opposite
councillor bonds because my view is the
proposal that we have in front of us the
application we have in front of us is
overbearing and it's out of character
with neighboring properties and for
those reasons only I just don't feel
like and support it I think it's it's
unfortunate from the applicants
perspective that I didn't consult with
the parish council but you know a lot of
applicants you notice it is
learning process but I'm not happy with
the design and I feel it's squeezed in
we're typically on that side of the road
and particularly South that part of the
village I think part of its character
Engadin is some very nice properties
surrounded not crammed in not crammed in
I like I don't feel I can support it for
those grounds Perry the second to catch
the brain in the core strategy with the
five-year and surprise supports us as
well and I think that should be in there
as well as what's been said that's the
balance he okay with you content with
that being with the appeals that I've
done I believe that size bulk and mass
is you can add them with a greater few
but I don't think okay but you are
content for us to add those as reasons
thank you well I do feel the the latest
figures on the the new five-year housing
land supply it it is significant it's
the highest it's the highest figures
that we've we've had at six point seven
five years and I do think it's
significant okay so we'll add those as
reasons for refusal I can't slow down I
just have concerns regarding the lack of
engagement with the parish council
because actually that they could have
had some feedback about what was
required and design and also I think
we've got to be really careful about
being so flexible with with quotas and
percentages because where do you stop
but I'm not sure how much planning
grounds you can go for refusal except
for is it this is ever bearing on a
smaller plot is that what we're saying
okay and in Congress with the
surrounding is that the to okay okay
Richard John just go through those for
us and then we'll go to about
so the first reason for fusion would be
effectively a numbers reason and the
policy says 16 in effect Gaiden is now
at a point where it's more than around
8% so that would be the first reason the
second reason would then be that this
particular scheme is out of character
okay so all those in favor of refusing
the application based on the reasons
stated you know miss Chairman thank you
committee therefore resolves to refuse
application reference 16 / 0 2 4 7 9 /
ful we also need to vote on whether or
not we continue the meeting at this
point it because it's getting quite late
we would still be queen if we let's take
the vote first
are we unhappy to propose we continue do
I have a seconder to continue thank you
all those in favor of continuing all
right thank you therefore we will
continue the meeting
once 17 / 0 0 5 2 1 / ful site addresses
plot to land north of Green Lane ox Hill
and is for the full application of a
dwelling and in you access presenting
officer Andy Carter Andy over to you
thank you chair for planning permission
is sought for a new dwelling and access
on Green Lane in ox Hill as shown by the
black dot on the map a single dwelling
has previously been approved on this
site in 2016 the application site is
located to the west of ox Hill with news
early with newly consented dwellings on
either side here is a recent view it's
an aerial shot showing the application
site outlined in red you can also see
the newly built for bed house on plot
one immediately to the west further
along the newly compete completed for
bed blacksmith house is also shown on
the plan plot three to the east of the
application site also has permission to
build a four-bed house as this piece of
land here this slide shows the view
across the site from Green Lane with the
house on plot 1 in the background just
there and this slide shows the view from
the site looking towards the east this
slide shows the footprint of the new
building in comparison to the consented
schemes on either side so you see the
similar footprints between three plots
and this slide shows the front elevation
of the dwelling with a render with a
combination I should say of wooden
cladding and a render I don't think
there are any updates to this ones and
recommendation is to ground thank you
very much just confirm this is based on
the Serta here for objection from the
parish council thank you move to our
only speaker registered which is the
ward member councillor fielding
so you have five minutes but please
don't feel you have to use it all okay
se use it all up when I spoke to the
chair of the parish council
prior to this tell him that I was going
to go along with the planning officers
to grant it his comment was well I just
wanted our refusal to be to be noted so
really there isn't a lot of ants from
the parish council on this Green Lane
has got several I did have you got some
more photographs showing green the
houses along Green link because yes
because they've got mishmash of all
sorts of different designs and sizes of
houses squeezed from that one there to
what they refer to as the Shah to marry
down which has got planning beside it
but it hasn't been developed yet so as
you can see there are a lot of
developments squeezed into small plots
and hence the problem here which or the
reason why the parish counts for against
it the two previous applications left it
with 838 square meters the current
application increases it to 408 sorry -
to just over four hundred and forty
eight square meters plot 3 has planning
permission for 488 square meters
one of the reasons why the parish
council or referred to in there if wish
to refuse it was that he had five
bathrooms I can't see any bearing that
this would have in it the plot one is
373 but only four bedrooms in my opinion
the house fits within the property
although it is tight its
be difficult to get gardening equipment
around but I think that can be dealt
with and I see no reason why it should
be refused
Thank You counsel fielding any questions
for the ward member no that's the
fielding thank you it's brilliant
she had points of clarification or John
going straight to a vertical straight to
a vote mr. Bates
so dick Ulis this accounts like I'm
gonna have to ask you to move just step
away from the table
this is ridiculous mr. yeah proposed I
propose that we throw down all those in
favor of granting the thank you
committee therefore results grant
application 17 / 0 0 5 2 1 / ful then
perhaps we could ask counselor fielding
to go back to his parish council and
tell them they need proper reasons in
future yeah thank you wasting out time
thank you okay item 12 ladies and
gentlemen so this is on page 1 2 1 and
this is here to reference 17 / 0 1 1 3 2
/ ful hang on hang on
12 farley Avenue Harbor 812 Farley
Avenue Thank You committee sheesh at 12
Farley Avenue Harbury single-story
extensions fronting area two-story
extension to side and rear of existing
presenting officer Richard Gardiner I
think you need to give us a bit of an
idea about it before he was going
straight to it but if that's all right
thank you
just just
okay I can't [ __ ] I'm very sorry I can't
the presentation okay I'm going to do
the old-fashioned way then I've got file
it's a planning application for single
story extensions to the front and rear
of a detached property in Harbury so
we're on the western side of harbor
either this is a row of 1960s detached
properties of red brick with profile
clay tiles and what they would like to
do is to do fairly substantial
extensions it's never been extended
before and you will see that they're
extending on its southern side in fact
start at the front you can see the porch
there has been extended so it's a front
extension wouldn't usually be allowed
but in this picture here that's right in
this context it's considered acceptable
and on the southern side there there's a
one and a half story side extension
there the dormer in the roof
can I move around to the rear there's a
two-story element and then there's a
flat roof balcony which would have a
glazed of pure glazed or a farrier there
to avoid overlooking to the neighbors
act supposed to be controlled by
condition and then obviously the
single-story below and that's the
proposal
thank you we have no speakers do have
any questions Thank You counsel ants
we grant I presume count some Mills I
think wave just in time your second I'll
second that
as you know always look at the ease in
this it looks good to me thank you very
much okay should we go to the vote all
those in favor of granting please show
you no no mr. chairman thank you the
committee there for the results to grant
application are from 70 and slashes 0 1
1 3 2 / ful this committee thank you
very much for your patience tonight some
tricky decisions thank you for staying
so long mr. McKenna can i no be put back
to the battle board member and the pair
counselor that they should attend these
meetings yeah by just objecting because
I feel like it nothing I think it might
be something for us to raise with the
ward member at some point well next time
this group meeting thank you the meeting
is closed thank you very much everyone
thank you